le bas de gamme de cette semaine et
présenté par revivent vous connaissez
sûrement un vive pour l'heure smoothie
mairie vient de lancer une nouvelle
gamme de lunch on les a essayé c'est
complètement une scène you le tome
taille le banc le chili et le mcs squash
qui est un genre de match is qu'on a
fait en fait chez nous puis on va vous
montrer comment ces rapides watson
gueule si votre but
p as tu es qui ai commencé face il se
fait remarquer mme cheese avec le mac
and cheese le mcs squash 1e div en fait
fait que j'ai pris une petite rondelle
comme ce j pop et les 6-15 l'atrium
pardon dans un bol avec un peu d'eau
trois jeux dans le fond ça donne ça ici
j'ai des macaronis qui sont des fuites
fait juste mais cela d'un boss un peu
puis ça fait un manque de test est
pauvre c'est débile pour le pain que
c'est un trip et en plus c'est pas mal
vous sentez qu'elle matin qui est
rationnel donc un bon repos pour les
gens occupés les gens qui veulent bien
manger c'est naturel c'est vegan c'est
sans additif c'est un repas complet et
on a un code promo ou sans fil pas de
casser sans filtre podcast 10 pour 10 $
de rabais sur votre 1ere commande alors
bon appétit le podcast de cette semaine
encore une fois présenté par même skate
vous les connaissez on en parle souvent
c'est des produits pour l'entretien sous
la ceinture que nous mêmes on utilise
vous savez que la saint valentin qui
s'en vient que vous ayez des couilles
que votre partenaire déco et quoi de
mieux que le perfect package 3.0 pour
l'entretien couillet qui est un mot que
je viens juste inventé
vous savez pas besoin des petits
chocolats dans un coeur une petite
attention non un même skate d'homme on
trippe sur le même score par le mans
peluche mois le ca fait pas si mon
rituel mannequin j'ai pas besoin le
showman skype s'accaparer les pauvres et
ça va vraiment bien c'est pas pour rien
qu'ils aient plus de 2 millions d'hommes
qui les amène script ses droits une
technologie révolutionnaire jamais eu un
rasoir électrique de ma vie km 112 bien
pis je le dis en tout temps a été
vraiment demandé d'embaucher jamais rien
qui reste pris ça va super rapidement
c'est bling bling c'est réglé après cela
tout doux le tout à touques ligne de
parfums au kenya ont eu des bons petits
produits ici qui semblent bons pour
cette région là un petit des odeurs on
met ce toute la journée pas d'inquiétude
ça va sentir bon et le parfum huit fans
qui est vraiment une odeur incroyable
ccc shaul ces choses parfum le show pour
la saint valentin c'est parfait le fac
et je vous recommande vraiment ya
cependant que le pam aux autres vous ne
connaissez c'est le sans filtre pour 20%
de rabais et le shipping gratuite sur
commence si vous commandez pardon dès
maintenant vous allez l'avoir pour la
saint-valentin atteint pour raviver les
flammes de votre amour donc merci la
gagne domaine skate puis bonne saint
valentin à vous fans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut avec noah 8
hausse de sitôt si je suis yes men grand
bonheur et plaisir de re recevoir est
symbolique est devenu super de castres
au long time ago
loana et demi après
on avait parlé de sa carrière de foudre
ne parlait pas la faire et on a élargi
la discussion surtout plein de nouveaux
sujets un goût toujours aussi
passionnant et et le caïd rôle est
gentille bowie merveilleux on a parlé d'
activité physique qu'on a parlé de sa
routine journalières on a parlé du fait
de se lever à 3h30 du matin ce qui fait
ces temps ci on ne parle y de longévité
on a parlé de ces nouvelles brend de
sacs tribe reine de boissons sans alcool
on a parlé de dépendance de parler de ça
commence à faire le tour de parler de
plein de sujets intérêts d'emprunt
direction c'était super intéressant et
j'ai adoré ces discussions après chaque
podcast deux mois et nicole ont fait un
encore moins de filtres donc on discute
de la conversation convient d'avoir on
approfondit nos réflexions et ça c'est
disponible exclusivement sur notre page
pétulant donc on va mettre le lien dans
la déception du podcast abonnez-vous là
encore ça se crée une belle petite
communauté pétulance et excitant sans
plus attendre commenté tom hop tout le
kit mais surtout bon pas de castres
bonne écoute
[Musique]
c'est parti et tiennent à saluer comme
régulier par deux deuxième bon petit
bout tivement ça faisait longtemps un
ami deuxième épisode 50 cake mais on est
rendus 530 15 mois ok mais quand même je
me sens comme un habitué le vert
on rappelle l'élu rappelle l'élu
c'est donc elle qui a lancé l'idée
d'être invitée parce que tu as fait une
vidéo comme qui était sûrement mieux en
parler que moi sur la motivation je me
suis et pourquoi c'est déjà parce qu on
était deux petits mois on était comme un
peu dans un jardin moon ou est ce qu'on
voyait beaucoup de publications passé
sur les réseaux sociaux de qom
depuis tout à fait honorable mais demi
thème qui te prend sur l'accident la
pandémie sans toi au coupable de rien
faire c'est le tout comme fait une vidéo
pour vous pour craint qu'ils montent à
la porte mais cette piste est quoi mais
j'ai fait acquis lui dû vaincre équipe
et je sais ce que j'ai besoin d'attendre
jusqu'à prends soin de toi qui prends
soin de toi c'est ram un disque ok mais
c'est bien mais cliquer bien ou si c'est
bien à tout moment c'est vrai j'ai
besoin de me faire botter le cul ou s'il
a peut-être possible sur tout ce que je
dis doit faire des vidéos par rapport à
comment je me sens à ce moment là si ce
pauvre temps passé devant ce même mois
en lien avec la pandémie t oui prends
soin de toi we mean time money time
on était beaucoup j'ai eu le droit moi
ma blonde on avait les trois quais john
ami qui a emménagé pour le pour le
confinement qui fait que tout sauf mi
temps moi j'avais quasiment besoin
d'allumer sauver notre sous sol pour
commencer à travailler mais aussi le
fait qu' il ya quelque chose que je
trouvais bien excitant la menace
extérieure qu'on n'avait jamais vécu
auparavant puis je me disais à chaque
situation qui est stressante liées qui
est qui et qui est un peu oui il ya des
opportunités qui vont pas pepy le cheveu
à être prêts à se faire
ça a beaucoup choqué mais ces mêmes
business fonte et moi je me promenais
beaucoup aux quatre coins du québec un
d'or au 100 l'ontario pour me donner des
conférences
puis le tueur au lendemain s'est
tranquillement pas vite tu le sens où la
conférence pour la fin mars annulés
voilà j'en est booké jusqu'en juin s'est
fait que au keops avril mais aussi le
juin tombe tu fais comme tabarre nage
annulés ou reportés en septembre du fait
comme en septembre que ça va venir je
capable de te fiche que le puits
finalement tu te rends compte que c'est
plus gros fake
au lieu de jeu ça une passive peut
attendre nous faut que je sois dans
l'action que j'ai l'impression fait faut
être proactif qui fait que j'ai en fait
j'ai aucune idée de quelle vidéo tu
parles mais c'est une plus longue l'est
c'est très plausible au lieu juste
d'encaisser je veux pas juste rester
assis à jouer défensif puis mangé des
clachs ailleurs je dois faire des moves
puis je vais me planter puis pierre
maintenant je vois avancé que je vais
retrouver le sweet spot fait que c'est
un peu sur mon ma vision et mes mains je
me suis dit la même chose pendant leur
confinement avec le couvre-feu le tilt
je me suis donné un défi jardin de ford
pas tous les jours pour avoir un
objectif méthon mais pour ne pas subir
30 jours de confinement le team et en
profiter pour faire qu'il genre à bien
manger je jouais pas bon dans lequel je
vais m'entraîner à tout les jours puis
au moins ça me donne un objectif en
place de justesse chez nous fermons
méhul tort qu'est ce que je fais mais je
pense que dans des périodes comme ça
plus que jamais tu rentres pour moi j'ai
besoin d'une discipline de vie parce que
si le contexte actuel encore aujourd'hui
il était tout est fait en sorte pour
nous angoisser nous insécurisés on a
perdu beaucoup beaucoup de de repères et
des enfants qui étaient on croyait
acquis ne le sont plus puis
inconsciemment tu as beau très beau ça
m'affecte moyens ça t'affecte pareil
parce que on est encore en quête d'
essayer de trouver comment comment gérer
tout se fait à partir du moment où tu as
de la discipline des digues moi je me
lève à 8 ans je m'en vais m'entraîner je
faisais là franchement 6e l'instant seul
cette discipline la de ça me donne des
repères dans lesquels je suis à l'aise
confortable je me sens plus productifs
aussi un stand c'est quasiment une
problématique pour moi au niveau de la
productivité les joues rouges productif
chemin fia puis le géant top of the
world puis les journaux je ne me sens
pas assez productif entameront juste un
mot auditif est fait que cette
discipline cette routine là pour moi
elle est primordiale mais le problème
qui est arrivé quand le premier
confinement
c'est que j'essayais de l'imposer je
suis quelqu'un qui habite avec moi tipi
vie c'est drôle parce que mais kate moss
année mais ma conjointe de make up on
s'en est parlé récemment mais si j'avais
jamais été autant à la maison que ça
fait qu elle a une façon de gérer la
maison là où rôde à sa façon mais elle
est vraiment plus fruste heures puis
cool moi je suis vraiment plus jouer au
sort john fleck dit comme amman et à la
compétitivité
si tu veux avoir une discipline de vie
extraordinaire goût de feuilloux mais
moi je leur pose parce que ce sport mois
pile et les kits n'ont plus fait que
fait dieu un clash comme tout le monde
est déterminé mais mais bref moi j'ai
besoin de 6ème ou six mois si c'est
vraiment la même chose
et puis le confinement ccsa comme tu dis
ça ça brise toutes les habitudes tout la
routine quelconque titre est construit
je pense que lui-même vraiment dans une
routine le titre vaut n'importe quelle
personne performante
onetik une routine de vicky vraiment
solide 6 et hop on a tellement de
distraction autour de nous répéter des
plaies de petits tas fallait le
téléphone comme suit le premier d'une
journée à l'autre des fous de foot je
vais pas faire comme elle mais j'ai pas
besoin du téléphone aujourd'hui puis
pied d'autres d'affaires aussi qui
affecte le mot de ce énième mais les
journées j'ai remarqué c'est que
j'analyse beaucoup le si vous savez là
dans la foi juive non on ne parle un peu
de tout mais l'élève j'avais amené comme
tva nouvelles en loupe d'albert grande
journée puis je me suis couché soir le
angoisses et puis j'avais pas écouter
activement c'est juste toujours un peu
dans le background peu inconsciemment
c'est ce que tentent à pic qui se répète
dans ta tête tu le fais comme lui je
fais ma télé j'écoutais mon pied pour
une page et regarder les régimes et ses
collabos de pointe qu'est-ce qu'il faut
que cherchent les mesures vont changer
en
oui ok + enfants qu'on a parlé récemment
de ceux précisément sur le podcast on
earth une spécialiste du stress qu après
son nul pin trépied elle est si pauvre
et c'est un podcast sans fil très
écoutés mais toi je te conseille à tout
le moins possible les nouvelles
justement à cause que évidemment les
nouvelles sont centrés sur les nouvelles
négatives ou les pays bas inconsciemment
ça peut vraiment de stress ça t'affecte
puis après ça ça joue sur tournoi c'est
juste bien enfin qui n'ont cessé c'est
clair le faut pas trop avec dj lagarde
je vais l'écouter audiences parce que je
curieux de l'entente sk s'est prononcé
au niveau du jeu veut pas jouer pas
juste par des flashbacks à votre podcast
métier moi je trouve qu'on est dans une
drôle de période par rapport au
journalisme puis à la façon qu'on relève
les nouvelles avec un angle d je trouve
que de moins en moins de qualités mais
c'est pas tout le monde je peux pas
mettre tout le monde dans le même la
tomate à des nouveaux sites qui émergent
qui ne font que relayer des nouvelles
c'est du clic beit souvent pipi tu le
dis si le négatif - qui vint en même
temps faut passer des messages parce
qu'il ya des gens qui doivent comprendre
que c'est réel qu'il faut faucon qu'on
appela this cette fameuse courbe lemay
mais bref
des fois je trouve c'est too much aussi
dans la façon que c'est ce que le
message est envoyé un fax et s'est pas
prononcé exactement là dessus mais
première chose qu'a dit et puis après ce
petit monde lire ont écouté les branches
style la chose de plus important qu'à 10
il faut pouvoir le stress comme négatifs
le stress est normal dans vichy sur
l'éthique de ce coupé de toute source de
stress sera jamais capable puisse pas
nécessairement bon c'est fait qu'il faut
juste apprendre y ait des délais avec
puisque l'on parle de ce prêt si mam est
clairement qu'en ce moment il aimer dieu
ils sont comment capitaliser sur tous
les médias écrits crise tous les moyens
possibles clic bêtes pour essayer de
faire des revenus c'est ce qu'on voit en
ce moment c'est que ce pas c'est ça
c'est ça le problème en fait avec ses
lacets seule la crise des médias
c'est clair
on le sait le la seule la tonique les
les compagnies délaissent les médias
traditionnels pour le web avec le
nouveau fonctionnement du marketing
digital mais les médias se retrouvent
500 financement sans financement qu'est
ce qui te fait qu'est-ce qui fait
financer si les clés lecteur fait que ça
crie plein de sites déclic bête ça crie
même les médias traditionnels se créent
des sites déclic beit les bornes en
béton
tva sports tu peux savoir le kivu gaulle
et asseoir plus et vous ne croirez pas
que claude julien a dit sur le gardien
du canadien pleut c'est comme si quoi
que dix sept ans je clique dessus mais
je suis d'accord bi tah partir du moment
où tout le monde le fait mais c'est
qu'ils ont comparé la rédac
mais c'est vrai ultime ans sont dans une
game d'attention c'est plutôt génère
d'attention plus tu génères de revenus
wittmann et ses moniteurs que c'est
l'argent qui va qui va rouler ce mets
mais ça fait que j'essaie du mieux que
je peux d'aller chercher mon info ou
plus d'endroits possibles du pisco pas
toujours le cas par exemple parce qu'à
manille une question de temps aussi
lippi fait que j'essaie trouver des
sites le plus crédible possible si je
vois aller voir du si je vois lille vont
le téléphone ou la tva nouvelles jean
yves ordures à deux cas mais je vois
aussi depuis je me suis partout puis de
m'entourer de gens aussi qui vont vider
leur perception de tout ce qui se passe
aussi de plein d'angles différents mais
mais c'est une période qui est fascinant
tomber dans quelques années
regarde en arrière enfin quand on est un
solide costaud d'idées pas mal tout est
train de changer
comment est ce que la société réagit
plus les individus à l'intérieur même la
société comme ce que toutes ces
choses-là interagissent quand il ya un
stress en énorme
puis une crise anxiogène massive
nous savons maintenant c'est on va
savoir qu'on n'était pas bien équipés
oui pour gérer sûr parce que là avec les
clivages qui se crée entre lesquin puis
l'on n'a jamais été aussi séparés il
tranché dans nos opinion way puis c'est
comme s'il faut que tu ailles l'opinion
de suite sur tout pc par les y obliger
je trouve qu'il nous manque de mouvement
rassemblant a pity logement l'arc en
ciel
on va faisons face à la musique ça vaut
mais les niveaux
mais il ya moyen de trouver sa pitance
pis on a tout notre petit côté aussi on
pense à nous d'abord commence à nous
avec nous en premier je pense à mes amis
qui sont restés tard je pense à munich
son propriétaire de jim shaw je le
comprends et d'aller crier haut et fort
pitt phares comme gaz
vous voulez une société en santé mais
vous nous empêcher de nous entraîner le
notre alimentation est affecté notre
santé mentale et physique c'est un lien
fake fixe je le comprends mais en même
temps je te comprends aussi de faire
comme ben tu me tant que je regarde
techniquement parlant d'eux humain qui
sue à côté de l'autre
c'est peut-être propice à devenir un
foyers d'éclosion fake je trouve qu'il
n'ya pas de réponse parfaite
il n'y a pas de gestion idéal contente
pas être dans les souliers de françois
legault pi2 reçu arruda c'est bien mais
j'ai eu super meta j'ai un côté ou moi
même je suis frustré par toutes les
situations puis des fois je me dis comme
schumi street
on y participe pour un confinement de
quatre semaines comme ça va durer
longtemps
le feeling que j'ai c'est la même
frustration qu'acheter l'aéroport puis
que mon ton vol est retardé d'une heure
pl après une occasion aussi de la boxe
et 5 heures qu'elle arrive comme si je
pars à 6 ans je vais m'organiser par la
journée s'est fait un peu défaut nahd
mais d'associations j'ai le feeling
mettant le peps à pire mais tant qu'on
lui mente un petit peu comme une
question plus philosophique laitiers si
c'est la fin du monde que quelqu'un qui
le seul sait maintenant mettons que la
nasa ont checké en haut puis qui ont vu
qu'une météorite qui arrive pickeu dans
ils savent maintenant qu'ils sont au
courant qu ils peuvent pas envoyer bruce
willis pour faire exploser ça
la tonne selon que c'est comme un frère
mais effective étant maintenant la nasa
qui dans deux semaines c'est la france
visée mais tout dit shaw ligue thomistes
rides mais est-ce que tu préfèrerais
qu'ils ne disent ces méthodes comprends
c'est plus largement pour apprécier
ramener sa part la galette du préféré
quelqu'un dise veille
c'est ici la nature qui sortent font une
conférence de presse
royer le matériel dans deux semaines
c'est fini c'est les pires deux semaines
que tu as vu david rey il ya des
carreaux le monde se tire dans la rue le
monde il y tout le monde violent dans le
sens où je teins dirigeants je vois que
la météo les métriques s'en vient quand
on offre pas de hausse mais je garde les
gars guys hangers pendant deux semaines
vous allez être isolée chez vous
télémesure changeront pas j'ai pas
l'impression je sais qu'ils réévaluent
pire évalue relativement souvent mais je
pense qu'à ce stade si on peut savoir
que ça finira sûrement pas dans quelques
semaines mais si ça met le poing c'est
maintenant mettons que voilà deux
semaines qui ont annoncé le couvre-feu
le temps qu'avait dit un couvre-feu
pendant trois mois dans le monde est une
fille très rapide surtout avant ce
dernier je dirais herman dernier je
pense pas que personne ne s'attendait à
ce que ce soit si lent toute cette
histoire c'est moi je vois je vois
donner un exemple qui peut-être je suis
pas un métier en ontario rapidement je
pense c'est ton mode mi juin ils ont
annoncé qu'ils avaient pas de sport d
équipe qui allait se jouer à partir du
mois de septembre
le ca a été le monde a capoté y est en
mode il est bien trop tôt pour se
prononcer puis on dit non on garde la
ligne dure c'est ce alors qu'au québec
on a dit peut-être peut-être la précitée
panier pour gérer des déceptions car la
journée qui se pose est comment si
finalement tu tire la plogue succès à
moitié puisque je trouve ça bien qu'il
faut peut-être que je parle à travers
mon chapeau parce que je suis pas le
plus renseigné ce niveau là mais j'ai
l'impression que souvent on prend des
décisions que certains aspects plus
politiques
la boutifarre les hauts revenus et ce à
tout le monde au lieu de gérer titre
créé un comité de garantie sont en
période de crise puis
on lit que certaines infos pour tâter le
terrain
la population vont gérer ceux ci n'ont
finalement c'était pas vrai août c'est à
ça réagit bien mais le couvre-feu si par
exemple on l'attend on le tout sur une
semaine d'avancé
on n'est pas plus ploguer qu'un autre le
s'est voulu le symbolique ayant appliqué
soit pour la pauvreté le poulet web
c'est peut-être ça réagit bien bombe est
à part nos frontières et fx et odst est
coté là que je trouve tocci et en même
temps je le répète je pense que je fais
mieux alors cela dit clairement c'est
frustrant pour tout le monde
spécialement après presque un an
politiquement par la cgt pour tout le
monde s'est agi pour tout le monde c'est
là qu'un que le dos dans le fond il n'y
aurait pas de rien qu'ils peuvent faire
pour être élu c'est quand même toutes
les décisions qui vont prendre niveau à
la moitié du monde qui m'ont pas une
contemplions rien faire pour être bonne
solution non plus ce métier
au début tu vois qu'ils conférence de
presse à tous les jours moi j'ai été
nommé comme mais ils font face à les
museler la presse en europe on participe
lundi rita puis chaque territoire est
décuplé dans notre perception de la
gestion de toutes ces émotions l'homme
et métiers à amman y avait un petit
manque de transparence et comment vous
avez pas pris de notes remplies jamais
d'aucun meeting avec la santé publique à
key west et puis les gens souhaitaient
des réponses
quelles sont les données qu'ils ont fait
en sorte que vous avez pris sa décision
le pseudo systèmes complexes à générer
des frustrations mais je pense que dans
l'ensemble paraître si on regarde aussi
les derniers sondages qui sont sentis le
thi lac a quand même la cote encore avec
avec les gens pis moi je crois pas un
gros stratagème machiavélique mondiale
contente jamais avoir sur lui mais c'est
pas le matin faisait je vois [ __ ] le
bordel je vais même temps le monde
adopté la semaine passée leur single
s'appelle rémi quirion lancé le
scientifique en chef du québec et qui
est menacé comme un poste comme un
espace de rôle offert par le
gouvernement à un scientifique qui plus
est ce que tu tentes de réfugiés entre
lens le gouvernement puis différents
scientifiques gouvernement se pose une
question sur mettons qu'est ce qu'on
devrait faire avec l'affluence le végal
ici et maintenant ils donnent des
bourses pour des chercheurs de facom
sautiller sur le rôle qu'ils disaient
pire je sais que c'est pas un dico qui
est que tout le monde a envie d'entendre
parce que des fois quand souffle tant
pour le goût de te faire dire ce
possible que ce mais non pas chez moi ça
me fait quand même du bien trudy tel
confinement ces plates le sicile puis du
monde qui souffre de manques sur bien
plus que moi mais n'empêche que dans
l'humanité mettant de comparaître le
zinc guerre mondiale ou télé grande
guerre où j'aurai à la peste noire ou
jardiner pintor le moyen-âge pitt se
sait vraiment pas ce qui s'est passé ne
rien montrer que l'esprit m couvre-feu
dans l'histoire du québec c'est première
guerre mondiale deuxième guerre mondiale
c'était quoi la crise d'octobre puis
pipe il fait comme mais moins deux
raisons on this post pire que ça en même
temps c'est facile à dire moi j'ai pas
perdu personne liée à la cage vide
je pense qu'on est beaucoup beaucoup
plus dans un an je tiens à ne pas
rentrer dans mon cas je peux pas dire
que je gêne pas bleu du virus parce
qu'aussi si j'ai 37 ans je suis
relativement en forme je pense que
c'était justement parlant ça serait une
très très mauvaise grippe
ça veut pas dire que je peux pas en
faire partie je pense que je mentirais
pape et je peux devenir un vecteur de
transport que ce que je souhaite pas
mais je suis plus axé vers prendre soin
de la santé mentale présentement que de
prendre soin de ma santé physique je
pense que c'est peut-être là où le bât
blesse plus aussi pas mal de monde j'en
aurai kirov puis c'est le stress
financier pour l'avoir vécu il ya
plusieurs années
c'est lourd à porter ben oui quand c'est
pas très capable de payer
bill klesse la seule affaire à quoi tu
penses quand tu dors quand tu travailles
et génère la honte aussi de la
culpabilité particulèrement c'est une
famille est une entreprise ou si tu
mettais tout peut-être aussi où tu
trouves n'y ait eu de point d'avoir tort
sait plus où tu fais comme elle je
vivais vraiment consciemment fait que je
pense que ça aussi ça fait réagir les
gens de toute façon mais tant parlé un
peu plus tôt l'élève les périodes de
stress d'angoissé de crise comme on vit
là ça fait ressortir toutes sortes de
façade chez des jeunes c'était peut-être
majeur écoute je fais juste celle des
matins blêmes facebook ce que tout le
monde respecte au moins une nouvelle
facette de cette personne devrait se
fiche pas
j'aimerais ce qu'on veut mais aussi les
fourneaux et on a tout juste eu mal à la
main mais cherchons colossus sonia dit
on a tout pété une coche à mener dans le
confinement le moment une petite houle
tout le monde va m'amener à cette
situation la piste stress l'anxiété que
ça à sa cause et manière le type est une
fille tellement pipi quotidien on est
divisé c'est ultra polariser les moutons
ou les complotistes comme moi je les ai
veillé les endormis tle droit de filer
entre les deux mais des fois tu aux
politiques b j'y suis les règles mais je
me pose des questions aussi parce que
l'opt et est apte pour des questions
matete complète avec moi j'aurais
tendance à dire aux gentils comme site
de quelqu un dans ton entourage qui qui
vraiment qui rage ou qui revendique
plein de se pose plein de questions
certaines qui ont peut-être peur à pas
cher qu on m appelle aux dons
c'est comme ricciardo lieu de les
insulter au lieu de les ridiculiser au
lieu de lecture de ta vie ben ouais tu
sais comme apple bi sas et déraisonné
comme écoute pitt c'est juste je pense
que ça crie plus fort sur peut-être une
espèce de détresse seront difficiles
s'en va seul à dire mais je pense vous
trouvez manière de prendre ce type bac
tu t'y mets ton moi justement le télé
l'homme
le feeling qui avait était venu à
l'invasion tva nouvelles que tu avais qu
il sait ce que ça causait mois-ci most
et les réseaux sociaux kingston c'était
comme chacun sa grande que facebook
pilote voit justement depuis
puis 2021 alger comme petacchi faut que
je coupe seule thématique man moi j'ai
une opération blocage en cours
présentement ou jamais bloquer autant de
gens de mon gré ahmeti comme je me dis à
moi ce soit des amis proches c'est ce
que je disais maintenant que j'ai un ami
proche qui que je vois qui commence à
écrire un peu défaut et lipton si je
veux voir rester prêtre je vais essayer
de voir ce qui se passe mais je demande
à la communauté que j'ai bâtie à plein
de monde que je connais pas puis c'est
tout ce qui est ultra négatif insulte
aux tic génèrent la m présentement je
m'obstine et le floch l'âge parce que je
trouve ça moi aussi c'est quand même
aussi c'est sa moue city john fallou du
monde tout seul mais je veux juste moins
tu fais juste vraiment - tirs - sur
facebook - tu restes à g plus de temps
dans l'environnement de 10 puis ça fait
du bien plus de temps à m'entraîner je
tombe comme ph pas depuis 2021 et y est
peut-être deux trois journées que je me
suis pas fait de sport lancement ça tous
les jours
crème puis je te masser les et d'avoir
ma routine me lève à 8 heures le matin
ceddat comprimé affaires qui avaient
toutes été chamboulée depuis le
confinement des 2020 sap été l'année la
plus productifs moi je comme toi une
journée productive
je me couche le soir je me sens prêt
j'aime pas ce jeu vraiment mieux je me
sens mieux si j'ai fait du sport
si j'étais positif si j'accomplis
d'affaires la majorité et tout ce qui
est super bon le faut que tu t'en
souviens d'une fois que ça va repartir
et puis je ne sais pas à quel point ça
voir partir de sa boîte pour le bain
progressive graduelle et c'est comme ça
a été le cas pour pour tout changer
d'armé mais de se souvenir de ce qu'on
faisait de bien pour pourrait embarquer
dans l'espèce de train les deux points
full non c'est clair c'est que tu ne
dois pas le confinement à recommencer à
travailler radio comme on parle tantôt
si j'ai vu tant à partager une petite
reprise de ces sites web bord du lac
saint jean a dit à l'écrire ainsi en
avant grâce à travers radio high school
l'autre ier radio que l'on me lever
vraiment le bonheur alors tout le reste
de la journée pour exister au privé
utile sinon plus que l'après-midi partir
complètement je suis le mans 6 mais
c'est réel c'est sûr c'est vrai si je
travaille avec mélanie maynard keynes
est une machine folle énergie parce que
ça fait dix axes une brève roule vite
laisse une vraiment aucune chance
qu'elle est là parce que ahmad au poteau
gauche puis on a une belle équipe une
belle citation à week-end même
effectivement c'était peut-être un peu
naïf de ma part de me dire comme mais
moi je dis je lève tôt en partant puis
c'est pas mal confinement panne a promis
confinement sachant que moi d'où je
viens en direct commencer puis sachant
aussi que c'est comme on y tenait ce jeu
dans une maison avec plein d'autres j'ai
ce jeu-là être productif moi je me lever
à 4h30 du matin fait qu'à 88 ce que je
faisais je me levais je m'en allais
najim phare un petit mil ou aux cartes à
précieux jallet marché d'un quartier de
mieux apprécier j'arrive et je lisais
une demi heure puis le à ce moment les
rangs du 6h30
je faisais déjà des courriels une
demi-heure 7h comment tout le monde
commence à s'élever tranquille map j'ai
déjà tout gérer c'est du temps pour moi
petit je me suis dit en faisant se
jetant trading pour m'élever une heure
plus tôt ça dès 3h30 3h45 quand chez
nous un peu au parti mais dans ma tête
je me dis ben thaber loge ses 3 45-3 et
demie debout cat et demi à la station
j'étais j'ai déjà préparé le show un peu
la veille je peaufine les derniers à
faire 5 il mis en ondes jusqu'à 9 heures
ont débriefé en place pour de la main
jusqu'à 10 heures j'arrive à mardi heure
et demie toute ma journée à moins d'une
journée de travail d'un corps brûlés
puis j'ai sous-estimé ce parce que c'est
pas juste de j'ai vraiment tout essayé
de placer parce que faut que je décale
mon cycle de sommeil très complète ma
carte je veux que l'habitant 8h30 c'est
pis c'est correct parce que les enfants
ce que je vois en ce temps là puis moi
je préfère avoir plus de villes matin
que le soir qui met vite et je bois je
bois post faisait plus de quinze ans par
le président axonais 8 mai mais ça c'est
que je me dis ben c'est ça un petit chat
juste décalé
clairement ça va prendre du temps parce
que ça fait trente exane et que j'étais
habitué d'avoir un certain succès mais
c'est pas juste c'est toute l'énergie
que ça prend aussi pour dire si vous le
voyez vous menez un podcast votre 130e
chose vous êtes habitués mais il ya
quand même la préparation
y'a des épices c'est en serez associé
cet organisme effet cette pression là
vous revient à vous si elle me remette à
mort c'est fou qui prenait la fecq mois
trois heures et demie par matin en
direct à la réponse aux morceaux itunes
c'est la job et puis ça s'apprend
d'énergie fait que je t'avoue que tout
sauf que je pensais que c'était une
bonne semaine même si je n ai pas vu
quelque chose parce que j'ai été
disciplinés avec mon home on a deux
dodos ouais mais un soir défaut de ce
fait comment je vais te fiche qu'elle ne
finisse powell mais s'attend à lèvres
noires de sa mairie fait le lendemain
était ko puis la fatigue pour moi ça se
transpose 1
je cherche mes mots j'ai moins envie de
chercher mes mômes aussi je commence à
chercher mes mots je le mets à stresser
plus de stress plus de chercher mouloud
fait des gros seins en ondes
c'est pas cool c'est comme si c'était un
défi extraordinaire en même temps
qu'elle et qu'elle courbe
d'apprentissage extraordinaire de
travailler 2 1 avec tes mélanie qui est
une communicatrice formidable puis juste
d'avoir la répartie d'avoir à gérer ce
3h30 par matin cinq jours semaine c'est
vraiment je suis je privilégie pour
ouvrir présentement pittis pour ce que
si on parle de coved à quel point ça
nous affecte des faucheurs lui aussi en
même temps je prends un petit peu de
recul je travaille plus que jamais j
plus de constance que j'aimais mais
malgré ce jeu vie quand même du stress
ce que je peux pas m'imaginer quelqu'un
qui a peut-être une situation petit peu
plus précaires qui est plus fragile
entre les deux oreilles que je le suis
présentement c'est pas évident à gérer
c'est sûr que non c'est sûr que non puis
les autres sont le fait des fois le pont
le fait des fois on le fait souvent tu
venais enregistre en podcast qui
convient à la part qu'on a fait ensemble
quand qu'on va pas retomber brûle away
savez pas ce que c'est c'est
intellectuellement brûlant pis ce que
moi mettons je fais quand je me sens
fatigué de même parce qu'elle est si
l'apec qui travaillent tellement je
m'entraînais l'hawaiien puis le
l'énergie revient c'est comme clerc est
complètement genre de rhuys être
c'est son corps ce qu'il faut que je
fasse s'étoffe de ce botter le cul quant
à ruffier était comme un peu basée à peu
dans son monde dans ta bulle tindouf ça
nous arrive tout le temps mais quand
après si tu mettais moi je mets mes
souliers
je veux courir quand je reviens l'espèce
de bugs dans ta classe de brouillard si
toutefois la nouvelle route int être
capable encore de glisser sur
l'entraînement dans un monde idéal ce
que je ferai passer après avoir parlé
avec déjà un monde fonctionne depuis
longtemps c'est drôle j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour ce que vous faites
parce que si vous n'avez pas joué
d'enregistrer le soir c'est mon histoire
si je suis plus fatigué on dirait que
c'est moins le club che - précipite
continent mais dans mes déplacements
dans la façon de le communiquer mais à
la limite moi je changer parce que le
cheviller le matin le matin c'est là que
je suis en tout cas jouer au foot ce
thème emerging c'était le matin mais
dans un monde idéal le même temps que
même ma page est blanche le pour ma
journée
betty trois et demie debout cat et demi
à la station je fais chose qu'à 9oo
début jusqu'à 10 j'arrive à 10 et demi
que je m'entraînerai une heure chez moi
ou où la vie me le permettront dean fils
y est loin de la pression j'aurai comme
la fin d'après-midi pour pour vivre la
personne avec les enfants mais c'est
parce que mon jeu fait pas juste la
radio s'est faite sur le sort fait
partie d'autres de la brenne j'ai
d'autres projets en branle qui me font
triper fake finalement j'ai jamais
réussi à instaurer cette routine le fait
que le peu de fois où j'étais capable
d'intégrer un créneau c'est comme les
tuniques de remise en forme où tu ne
fais que dépenser de l'énergie sur 100
pas encore les effets dans récupérer je
parlais de 5th tpiy lo'jo pitite la
recherche du bien être du bonheur de
tout le monde est un peu après sur un
trépied toutes sortes de litres millions
de lignes qu'on décrit là dessus un
million de théorie là-dessus de cépie
chacun
à 110 200 km et est stable à acheter
dans le fond le seul vrai conseil ou le
meilleur conseil revient règles de vie
pour mme et on a pu s'approcher de ce
ces stars du sport pauvreté je pense que
la chose que tu peux refaire qui va le
plus grand impact positif sur toutes les
autres entités je peux pour des gommes
aux autres oui j'en donne 100% ce que tu
veux dire au niveau bienfaits pour le
corps au niveau d' instaurer une
discipline au niveau des dans le moment
présent au site inactifs et du sport
n'est pas supposé penser à des problèmes
en dehors ou 4 qui arrive mais
rapidement tout était en plein milieu
d'un défi physique faite par la force
des choses qu'ils pensent pas trop
longtemps métier pour certaines
personnes c'est peut-être de dessiner
c'est peut-être de jouer au piano si
c'est peut-être mais je pense que
n'importe quelle activité comme ce qui
permet de plonger motive ce qui m'aide
beaucoup ces temps ci à décrocher des
réseaux sociaux entre autres c'est de
lire je me dis garde vos justes je parle
juste amusé je vois juste cinq minutes
ne l'est finalement servir un petit peu
plus longtemps que ce pipe
après cache le livre n'est pas au goût
de retourner ce téléphone tandis que
j'aime ça m'aide à me déposer alors que
le téléphone me stresse parce que j'ai
des fois je vais me retrouver à être
seul téléphone puis je n'ai pas reçu un
message j'ai pas besoin de faire c'est
comme toute nature de liste des fêtes
mais comme à la recherche de quelque
chose à faire je sais pas quoi fait que
je vois si je vois pas passer du de la
messagerie est à gramat cesse facebook à
mon texte puisque meilleurs et pourquoi
j'ai dit c'est spécifiquement j'ai
l'impression que peu importe la chose
sur laquelle tu t'en forme et on savait
tout le temps ça vient vraiment souvent
à ce thème et on connaît l'exemple par
là je parle encore de
de madame stress le soigneur à 10 est
plus je lisais son livre liard pied dans
le fond a dit dans plein de trucs pour
apprendre d'élections stress que gérer
son stress va diminuer son stress quand
tu es vraiment le dans tes dans une
crise aux pays dit à temps plein de
trucs qui respire par la bd inverse si
facile la chose la plus efficace c'est
d'alphadi pas 15 minutes minutes juste
est passé tout un bloc d'énergie en toi
bouge fait quelque chose ça peut être
n'importe quoi mais bouge qui chauffe la
meilleure chose après sam et on met le
monde n'ont pas toujours envie
d'entendre
parce que c'est ça ta timotchuk premier
est vrai ça me tente pas d'y aller mais
j'vais l'exercice puis fait c'est
peut-être fait les hommes animés il ya
dessus une fois où tu allais faire du
sport ou de l'exercice ou te regretter
de données jamais mais souvent en prada
tu fais comme à strasbourg
j'ai nagé pendant 25 années de ma vie
depuis ben je me disais yes j y ai payé
comme un parti peut-être les
compétitions des les conversions souvent
les pratiques mail il s'entraîne demain
jean huit fois sur dix j'y allais un peu
de recul on a faim genre qui exclut la
fois le tueur
la seconde c'est commencer tec est
également une bulle où est-ce que tu
oublies le fait que sa tante est plus
titrés comme dans une bulle de sept
jours 2 heures c'est comme un espace
temporel ou est ce que tu es plus
d'autres parents secteur sport la
seconde que c'est fini le meilleur
feeling mais je fais mon point après
soucis et mettons tout un forme ce qui
m'attend j'ai des problèmes de sommeil
ce volet là dessus meilleur truc
feuilleton sommet du thym forme sur
mettons la longévité
puis georges bizet l'arctique là dessus
c'est hills est pratiquement 100% des
gens qui ont vécu ce centenaire et plus
c'est des gens quittent activités qu'il
n'était pas nécessairement qui courait
le marathon métier mettons que même dans
la
la mobilité c'est la chose la démarche
non plus démarche toute leur vie des
longues marches se fait jeter comme
surtout chemin forme
le truc qui me disent j'ai fait du sport
soit je me dis ça me semble être la
chose après l'autre film à développer
des maladies
quand je fais du sport je rends
l'impression que c'est comme une affaire
à changer des habitudes intégré sol et
il faut qu'il intègre puis je vous parle
en même temps je me parle en même temps
je vais me répéter je suis pas motivé
parce qu'on parle de ce peuple m'a
traîné mais ma difficulté présentement
c'est de l'intégrer quotidiennement dans
un horaire qui porte toujours pareil
journal aussi la suivante il faut qu'on
intègre meeting important parce qu'il ya
telle affaire m alors il faudrait pas la
première chose qu'on coupe qu'ils ont ça
devrait être une priorité en ce moment
est tantôt le j'avais on n'avait pas
beaucoup de temps à la porte avant de
venir ici puis là c'est quand même un
qui est logé j'ai transmis ne gémit 1 1
identity work hard sur youtube
c'est en fait ils veulent sur les plages
les fêtes me suis décalé c'est puis la
fin à ces gens qu'ils aiment c'est juste
trente minutes un petit bloc de rien je
prends des douches rice est complexe et
si parfaite entre les deux
moi j'ai pas deux heures à mettre ses
mots le problème c'est aussi c'est que
je me sens tant que moyen d'y aller je
trouve que je pars de loin ne jeu mais
les dernières cartes j'ai fait j'en ai
fait semaine dernière 1
l'autre met en avant deux c'est puis un
petit peu pendant les fêtes mais j'ai
fait du tapis roulant
j'ai fait le job on est dans une journée
où j'étais comme un facteur de moyens je
vais marcher je vois jogging et variés
comme se dit juste ça me fait un peu
niais d'un ruisseau que je sache je
devrais faire plus mais je défends
l'exercice de bouger c'est fait pour
n'importe qui peu importe ton niveau
prendre l'air à l'extérieur oui des fois
j'ai
je sous-estiment à quel point tu seras
bien avons appris à prendre une marche
mais surtout l'hiver ou moi je suis plus
sédentaires moins deux qui tripent sur
les skis puis le synopsis être que le
fait de faire l'effort de sortir de la
maison
au lieu de passer d'un endroit intérieur
un autre endroit derrière ben ça fait
vie ou ses premières erreurs que je
coure vraiment dehors j'arrête octobre
novembre parce que le contre-pied de la
neige puis après on voit que je le fais
parce que pas de dilemme qui justement
sortir dehors ça fait vraiment bien peu
d'air frais puis même s'il fait moins -5
que le testament bien qu'ils rentrent
l'imposant avoir travaillé deux fois
plus tout sens bien ça prend une bonne
douche le site et sa maison puis tu
parlais de la longévité tantôt et puis
on veut mais je veux absolument qu'on
reçoive un spécialiste de la longévité
ici parce que c'est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup plus une science
qu'on commence à développer vraiment
être un piège écouter en podcast légué
s'appelle david sinclair c'est la
sommité mondiale en longévité
en ce moment ils sont encore indécis de
travailler à renverser le processus de
vieillissement sur la levure fait que la
levure que pour faire du pain m3 qui
kiffent ventre puis lyon réussit à le
fait que son temps de jeu que ce soit
pour dire que lui
les conseils qui avait c'était bouge
parce que la seconde que tu perds la
mobilité ça devient exponentielle
comment tu vieillis rapide - fait que le
tue pas et guerre mettons qui grâce à
hordain baudot des courbatures parce que
y'a pas garder une assez bonne hygiène
de vie où il s'est entraîné tout croche
je t'aime et on a quelqu'un qui se mord
le dos en faisant les deux livres parce
qu'ils aient jamais fait ça de sa vie
puisqu'elle est capable d'aller au gym
parce qu'il sait ce clapet le dos le ca
devient exponentielle que matthew
vieillissent vite
ouais le mot en voyant le 30 arrivée
j'ai eu 30 ans la semaine passée d'un
voyant temps d'arriver bonne foi je
remercie
j'ai comme commencé à réellement
m'intéresser à ce trait pour me dire
comment comment je peux parfois proches
management non mais pas la fin approche
métier dans tous les sports le titre on
sait comme 15
un athlète arrive à 30 c'est pas mal le
pays qui de sa forme d'erreurs sont les
athlètes comme lebron james continue
longtemps il va rentrer le blog continue
longtemps ce parce que il ya mis
tellement d'argent que d'efforts dans la
longévité justement mais dire qu'il
aimait tant physiquement dans la race
humaine je suis rendue peu mal aux
hôpitaux fait comment je fais pour que
la pente qui descend soit beaucoup plus
longue que la pente que monte pour que
quand j'arrive à 60 ans choix vraiment
encore plus proches possibles de
comanche jumelles
ces media play il ya plein de façons de
le faire c'est petit mais je pense qu'un
des bons exemples
par rapport à la précédente enquête
arrête de bouger ses 16 voit beaucoup
chez les personnes âgées c'est la pente
du moment grand père par la longévité
est décédé à 102 au mois d'août au mois
de mai dernier puis il venait d'avoir
102 ap ils étaient 18 à 102 n avait pas
cinq ans devant lui mais il ya là bien
tu es capable de parler il était capable
de s'exprimer puis coved est arrivé
confinement la théologie et arrête de
bouger c'est d'entrer chez eux ça a pris
je pense de ce même marché chinois il
marchait dans sa résidence et sortaient
des petites courses y aller manger dans
la cafétéria en bas avec les autres avec
les autres zones affectées tête avec une
relation des réactifs dtcc aussi david
sinclair les interactions en personne
très regardé le plus le plus longtemps
possible des interactions de bijoux
ouais pas cette garde sa de garde à lui
mais cette garde aussi psychologiquement
très affûté mais mais je sais c'est
motivant de d'écouter ce piment juste il
ya comme quatre questions que je me pose
souvent quand je fais le moyen c puis je
vends ça s'exprime sur façon de
psychologie climatique qui je bois du
nord où une journée un petit peu plus et
difficile où je plus fatigué c'est jésus
bien dormi mon sommeil aura de quoi à
qui je me suis couché à grade qui ne
pourra pas où j'ai dormi quatre heures -
c'est normal que tu files moyens est ce
que je bois de l'eau cissé c'est si
simple et si difficile à la fois
bois 3 litres d'eau par jour facile je
capable mais je le fais pas je fasse un
jeu capable
ok maintenant combien est en bois c'est
ça parce que je te garantis que c'est
pas plus qu'un litre
c'est fait et est ce que je dors bien
est ce que je bois de l'eau est-ce que
je m'alimente bien je me suis tapé des
fripes et l affaire puis c'est comme
c'est facile de tomber dans ce patelin
spécialement chez vous dit tu t'emmerdes
fait part dé foot belge
je mangeais pas de faire une bonne
action j'encourage les commerces legault
si la quatrième question c'est est-ce
que j'ai bougé aujourd'hui type et à
partir du moment où tu t'es capable de
réellement faire un check à ces quatre
items le les chansons que tu vas aller
mieux je me sens pas mal c'est sûr
celui-ci après ceux ci et les quelques
jours même et là je me sens plus
hypocrite de parler de ça parce que j'ai
de la misère à loin c'est ça qui
distille une discipline c'est le très
difficile puis justement c'est quand tu
lui qui quelques tu te sens bien métiers
des fois tu y mets ton juste avant de
dire qui assoient je me couchais à 9h30
à soir ben tu peux manger une poutine
sauveur ce cas ni caractère dans le
temps il faut se permettre des affaires
parce que sinon mais emprunte un peu de
bonheur aux futurs
mais c'est ce que je suis venu c'était
le cantal schwank arg gérard grave pour
poulets ou un incident gros break free
europe au poulet salade revenus avec
frites
or est aussi le gars avec son but avec
frites de 15 minutes ou est-ce que tu
étais content un tabernacle
puis la seconde que leurs repas et
finike l'autre commence à goûter live
bush kassaraté ducasse at the fuck
dimanche dans un rack de fredo complet
de l'autre personne à côté qui a mangé
un petit drapeau poulet avec le cirad
peut-être mais ça peut être aussi bon
lait en fait pendant qu'il mangeait le
type le la seconde que c'est fini il y
en a qui craignent mais moi c'est drôle
parce que le repas du midi est ultra
important pour moi depuis des années dit
parce que toutes les décisions que je
prends présentement le dentier en dehors
de job c'est vraiment pour essayer
d'optimiser mon énergie
parce que plus d'énergie plus je pense
que je produis type luge petit peu mieux
je me sens puis le midi le cpo compile
si je succombe à la tentation de manger
afin de radio la semaine dernière mais
la commande de chez arthur de ses
auteurs c'est un sport qui amène un
sandwich déjeuner c'est tellement deux
espèces de tranches de pain d août
pilotes comme wow j'ai mangé de la
patente
j'ai voulu mourir toute la journée oui
j'étais fini avec le midi outils ou
après la radio c'est vraiment le truc
comme aujourd'hui c'est une super belle
journée mais j'ai pris des noix
je me suis fait un chèque de protéines
plus leur entrée à la maison j'ai pris
de quoi de plus notre activité de plus
léger fait que fait qu'il faut vraiment
moi je tends gourmands aussi effectué
ses deux ça près c'est parce que sa
discipline en bd ce faire mais amman et
va falloir que tu faut faire des choix
qui fait le choix de la discipline où le
choix d'avoir honte d'être un rattrapage
ou d'être c'est peut-être un petit peu
moins un synthétique d'un choix faire
peine tu es mieux de prendre celui qui
t'amène à quelle porte bien deux choses
le quand arrive le soir moi j'ai souvent
des mots cheese
j'ai souvent envie de décorer un sac de
cheap au complet puis parfois je le fais
puis dans le moment je compte le faire
mais les matins où est ce que je me
réveille
où est ce que je sais que la veille je
me suis revenu j'ai fait non on le
trouve à boire de manger des séries très
bon en verre d'eau puis les matins je me
réveille le lendemain ils sont comme des
termes en mieux mais t'as pas que la
veille
la digestion car ce rush la division
parce que trop mangé ce ca groupe
d'énergie est ce un problème et non mais
même au cij comme ça à partir de ce
groupe g un truc qui tellement cave mais
j'ai comme réalisé qu'après huit ans je
suis j'ai de moins en moins de
discipline moi pour me retenir de tomber
dans le sac de rohff aux outils daoudal
elle le resta célébrons avec les
boutiques
puis l'upi d'autres abandonnent mais
débiles mais à partir avant 8 heures je
capable du non après 8 heures je tiens
enfin avec ce que je fais un cauchemar
je m'envoie dans l'âge d'or où seul le
père ses propos révélés famille fait que
je m'envole un champ ou un beau vite et
je commence à me préparer pour pas avoir
à faire l'effort dans la montée se fait
casser et d'après thèmes brassés et à
s'embrasser sabote l'autre l'autre truc
par rapport à la nourriture que david
sinclair parle depuis puisse poursuivre
ses pourparlers c'est josé gérer ce
qu'on a et conçoivent quelqu'un mais lui
ce qu'ils disent et le déficit
calorifique fait qu en fait ce que tu
cherches sais que tu veux tu es que tu
es cellules se répare à place de
construire des nouvelles cellules fait
que tu veux réparer les cellules qui
était déjà explique c'est beaucoup mieux
que seul fait qu'un enfant quand mes
tantes et un over calories comme un
athlète qui veut gonfler qui veut
prendre la mascotte qui construisent des
nouvelles cellules mais quand tu veu t
cellules se répare fonctions en déficit
cadre ific
komatsu ben tu dépenses plus de calories
que dans un genre banquet fait que la
dea place de construire pour gagner de
la masse ou ou acculé tiers du poids
supplémentaire est en déficit
calorifique puis lui il représente
surtout en terme de beau temps qui est
ce que tu manges
mais quand tu le manges oui parce que
mettons que tu manges dans ta journée
avant 6 heures le soir mettons le tir
ton corps il brûle plus de calories que
si mettons wii ou dj rail brûle plus de
calories que si tu vas te coucher
ce trade avec leurs sauces et comme lui
il prend un peu le jeune intermittents
ne devrait pas trop manger le matin
avant 11h puis pas manger le soir
maintenant que fait que ça c'est aussi
aussi quelque chose le métier pomme pas
manger en innocent tout le temps et
c'est drôle qu'un
en 2008 quand j'ai fini la saison 2008
puis que j'avais des essais avec la nfl
puis je vais engager un coach me sied
pas son nom mais y était à la barre de
baseball canada au centre taux
d'audience et le je m'entraînais puis on
m'avait référer à lui parce que je
t'aime brûlés de ma saison j'étais
claquée si j'avais dès les essais les
plus importants de ma carrière avec la
nfl qui capte joué 18 games ont été
rendus au stade français comme
conséquence la coupe grey en 2007 mais
paient pas
puis je finis normale devrait prendre un
mois enfin trois semaines off avant de
recommencer à s'entraîner moi je peux
pas me le permettre
j'étais allé le rencontrer dans le but
de parler de hockey comment je fais pour
optimiser mon énergie pu garder ma shape
aussi parce qu'à la fin d'une saison de
foot maigri attend à droite dépose paulo
qui veulent mieux paraître pour une
équipe de nfl fake lui momie sur un plan
d'entraînement vraiment particulier un
plan d'alimentation aussi où il me
disait le ton quand il ya besoin de
charbon présente mathy fait que les
matins je veux que tu te bourrer le
matin parce que toute la journée pour le
brûler faut juste que tu mettes charbon
dans la machine là à partir de l'heure
du midi ou même à partir de ta première
collation du matin l'on va commencer est
un petit peu plus tard mais pour le
moment dans la situation que telle
ça te prend en beauce le matin de 6 hier
matin le dessus du but de réveiller ses
neiges mais avec un restant de gâteaux
comme fait je fais juste te bourrer
s'est dit ce qu'ils disaient ces cas
précis il m'a mis sur plein de plus
petits repas par jour 10 pour le
connaissent pas tous nommés puis pimms
et la mer afin que je peux dire tous les
peler les gens les plus cotés au monde
les plus définissez les culturistes les
culturistes c'est tout plein de petits
report à tous les jours parce que ton
métabolisme fonctionne tout le temps les
gens les plus gros c'est les sumos ils
ont besoin de ça puisque je savais pas
ce qui m'excite c'est que les sommes
obligés pas un expert mais ils mangent
presque pas de la journée il ya un seul
repas dans journée qu'ils prennent et
c'est une montagne calorifique cpie
probablement j'imagine pas loin avant le
dodo parce que ça se transforme tout un
groupe i et le google peau fake de
l'opérateur nous
le jeune intermittents il est super bon
selon moi si tu es brillant dans la plus
courte période où tu peux manger que ce
soit ce que ce que certaines personnes
font pitié il y avait beaucoup de femmes
par le passé qu'ils se faisaient des
régimes comme ceux où ils privaient
beaucoup beaucoup le dimanche 200 repas
par jour stade paul malan fait l'effet
contracte mais effectivement si les
petits repas mètres deux dards font mal
comment moi je le fais pitié encore le
jeu prend un expert loin de là mais
comment moi je le fais je me suis
informé par rapport à ce pour encore une
fois dans l'aspect de longévité
mon intérêt principal six as et mettons
que douze heures de repos ben tu peux
manger trois fois déjà les esprits bank
linth en route privée puis en faisant de
quad band standard le tri c'est juste
d'essayer de restreindre un petit peu de
moi je mets je me glisse beaucoup c'est
avec les collations c'est je sais que
une fois arrivée au dîner
je vais avoir faim puis quand je t'ai
installé particulièrement quand les
restos sont ouverts
tout ça doit le faire des bons choix
avec des fois je joue je sabote un peu
mon dîner genre une demi heure avant
je prends des noix et des noix pour moi
je trouve ça bon c'est je sais qu'ils
jouent ce siècle même nom complet est
ici aussi un point qui fait que si je
grignote de coin ou même j'ai déjà fait
sauter comme une demi-heure avant dîner
je prends ma part de protéines paf fait
que j'arrive au dîner j'ai pas su parfum
fait que le jeu prend déjà un meilleur
choix puis wissam sa main et damas at-il
fait que c'est des petits partis ce qui
est fascinant de l'alimentation ainsi
que d'une personne à l'autre
il faut que des coûts ce qui fonctionne
pour tous et si j'ai un ami qui me
parlait de son jeûne intermittent
il ya une capacité de faire le jeûne
intermittent pendant vraiment des
longues périodes il ressent des
bienfaits au niveau de son énergie
j'ai un autre gars qui me parlait baisse
et dominic arpin qui m'avait parlé utile
8 est devenu végétarien puis à booster
son niveau d'énergie car qui m'a parlé
de ce j'ai essayé j'ai fait en deux
semaines de végétariens tabarnouche
juste j'étais gpat a fait plus que deux
semaines j'étais brûlé claque et ça
fonctionne fox qui fonctionne pour un
vote pour fonctionner pour
autre signe apparemment dépendante de
base qui sont importants à respecter
mais faut il ya beaucoup de la flottille
mettons aussi dit mettant lui qui était
protégé t'as rien quels aliments y
occuper ou city parce qu'il commet
qu'ils mangent et comment que manger
avant versus peut être des crimes c'est
bien manger foule plus besoin des frais
légumes cette optique et en mange des
jeux et puis peut-être que toi tu auras
mon travail j'étais rien n'était pas
optimal de manquer certaines en faire
partie c'est la façon d'y gérer certains
aliments c'est dur c'est dur à savoir
mais c'est cool moi je suis cool
d'essayer des affaires quand même
l'objectif étant dans mon cas d'essayer
de trouver quelque chose qui va
s'intégrer plus facilement dans une
routine que je peux regarder sur une
période que de faire une coupure
drastique d'un régime c'est ce que tout
le monde pouvait que ça fonctionne une
personne est si petit et plus ainsi que
c'est exactement ce que la stat mais je
pense que comme c'est 80% du temps le
petit père de l'enfant un régime strict
toujours à prendre et ça marche
pratiquement jamais versus qu'est ce que
tu veux bill décédé bonne septs de vie
note-t-il manger sainement j'ai des bons
aliments dans le fond aussi le plus
mange de bons aliments tu disais 4 4 qui
n'était pas fermée de paul goût
d'arrêter ou jeff chiu cadeau parce que
parce que tu te possède cette fin il que
le faut je mange loeb ça me prend de
quoi t'es fait que ce match des bons
aliments tout le temps pendant jour nice
qui pourra train de priver tout le temps
tu pas d'écrit vignes de manger le sag
et chip ou du mac do ouais c'est ce qui
est plus facile depuis je pense que
c'est trop tôt 1000 points là dessus
aussi mais je pense que le team allèles
la game c'est d'être bien c'est
l'objectif de tout le monde on veut être
bien
puis on veut tout à fait le plus
longtemps possible parce qu'on est bien
pire ouais c'est sûr pis on ne comprend
pas toujours ces décisions là on oublie
que même la santé le plus que jamais
l'on en est conscient le sait c'est la
première enfants pitt il y avait le
reste va faire avec c'est comme tout le
reste le sait rien si la santé folie ma
philosophie j'aille un seul conseil
s'est fait du sport ouais t'es quand je
fais du sport je fais des bains
meilleurs choix alimentaires
qui le gère pas les gâcher ça mangeant
ce pauvre éprouveraient jeu plus en plus
j'en parle et ouais tout retombe de
demain je vais retourner au james avait
une autre affaire qu'il voulait parler
moi au premier confinement j'ai fait
sans vraiment le planifier trois mois
sans alcool que ce prix là mais je
m'entraînais souvent mais juste parce
que j'étais tout seul chez nous que ça
donnait pas dans le fond le tir de moins
d'occasions ouais je vais pas commencer
à boire tête devant chez nous l'été puis
qui sont premièrement loup est ce que je
le remarque et le plus la différence
c'est sur mes performances physiques
même pas proche c'est de jeter rendu
début de l'été quand on a des conflits
nés un petit peu j'étais au sommet de ma
forme à course à pied le 2 juin puis la
gestion de mon poids aussi parce que moi
tandis que je courais je voulais faire
des longues distances pour les marathons
tchèque et mon poids quand même parce
que chaque livre quand même nom mais
surtout surtout la multitude des cheveux
qui mon niveau d'énergie sur la
troisième affaire
ouais j'avais pas la tête dans le cul je
me levais tous les matins je me levais
avec plus d'énergie de ces métaux que je
prends une bière ou deux le soir c'est
pas beaucoup je me mets pas saoul mais
le lendemain matin j'ai tout le temps la
tête dans le cul j'ai vu que ça faisait
quatre ans que tu étais agents ouais
félicitations première main feu puis le
avec atypique dans le fond je sais pas
par où je veux prendre cette
conversation le seul sur l'alcool puis
ce qui est derrière atypique mais dans
le fond de moi tonton mission statement
avec atypique le berre avec la halle
avec mon moment pas retenu
jonathan robin et sa femme dans toute
leur équipe installations militaires qui
sont dans l'agroalimentaire depuis
quelques années déjà sombre sont à
saint-hyacinthe puis je vote raconte un
peu plus le début tout ça parce qu'on a
c'est vrai qu'on peut ça peut amener de
la plaine place pour la main qu'on veut
finir avec ça mais je l'attends ce que
j'avais rencontrés il ya dix ans à peu
près par l'entremise d'éric lapointe
l'ancien joueur de foot qui est un homme
d'affaires puisqu'on aspi puis on s'est
perdus de vue un peu pim appel au mois
de janvier février 2020 c'est pour me
féliciter il y avait vu tes achats
confinement est exact commence à parler
puis bâti j'ai quelques entreprises
j'aurais peut-être besoin d'un coup de
main pour la promo d'un brin de cette
étape sans moyens je dis regarde je dis
moi je jamais tu veux partir de courir
avec moi je serais plus souvent fait
parle parle jase jase peut on se dit que
dans des boissons sans alcool qui goûte
vraiment une boisson alcoolisée qui sont
quand même relativement faibles en sucre
qui sont faibles en calories comme ça
existe pas c'est à dire de plink bière
sans alcool l'instant fait que la game
est pas là c'est de sortir un autre
bière sans alcool et bacon des mots
sonnent continue à battre contre les
micro brasseries qui ont travaillé là
dessus depuis des années mora a pris
avec le 20e joueur dans un marché ça me
tente mois yéti pour toi personnellement
ce que c'était un enjeu méthon est ce
que tu disais des fois dame des landes
et partait dans les bars vécu chez vous
du christ que je prendrai un gin tonic
mettons même jour witi j'aimerais ça
avoir de quoi je voulais te connais mon
pc paname et mais ça fait 4 1 mais
pendant toutes ces années là les options
étaient limitées souvent ce que je
faisais dans les restos d'un parti c'est
un budget de 6 e m'avait dit si justin
clamato clamato
sinon tu le mojito qui est intéressant
dans les restaurants métier comme moi je
serais pas du genre arrivé chez moi puis
le faire quand même
légumes affectés on a réalisé il ya
plein de monde des jeunes al dans la
game de la bière sans alcool vin sans
alcool
il y en a quelques-uns aussi mais dans
les prés taboye n'y a rien fait quand on
a décidé d'aller explorer sur le premier
le premier qu'on a sorti un gin tonic
sans alcool puis pittham alors on le
trouvait super bon puis les deux sont
nés des coûts les quatre autres saveurs
un partnership avec sotheby's qui
détient il est un fait que fais tu là on
est en avant dans tous les jeux c'est la
folie furieuse bizarre non parce que sa
part chaque fois que je veux juger
l'état leur apporte bon sens qui on est
après prendre les solutions qu'il faut
pour capable de fournir la demande mais
on a été agréablement surpris par le
boss qui on l'avait un peu je peux dire
qu'on l'ait veulent échapper mais si je
me dis ok je te porte parole naturel
pour pour ça parce que c'est un produit
que je bâtis pour moi pour l'utiliser
qui lui très cohérent avec qui je suis
stratégie de carrière au site tout ce
que je bâtis depuis des années sur les
réseaux sociaux on se fait d intégration
commerciale de temps en temps je me dis
ben team pour moi avoir mes propres des
pme de faire la pub pour désinformer
propre entreprise
fake ya ce on se dit c'est aussi dans
l'air du temps on en parle de plus en
plus de personnes sont conscients qu'ils
veulent diminuer la consommation
d'alcool pour des enjeux ne sont plus
que jamais je trouve que les gens ont à
coeur leur santé seppi réalise les
bienfaits de diminuer l'alcool je trouve
que nos jeunes aussi avec l anjou 30 1
re à tabriz
mais si les liquides de sept 7 8 9 à 21
stars sont moins accès sera peut être la
face comme une sorte d'alter c'est fake
je me dis qu'ils nous entendent pas ils
vont pas sans mal
mais mon point ce que je trouve qu'il ya
comme un
archives employé comme un chef comme une
popularité sur la sobriété comme de
times n'a fait que l'on se dit ok on a
un produit qui bon au goût on a un porte
parole qin naturel je capable de pousser
ce produit le puits en plus c'est dans
l'air du temps par rapport aux besoins
de plusieurs personnes la société fait
que me semble que tout est mis en place
pour que sa fille tshombé de vue comme
nous fait qu on est 6 niveau 2 avec 1 0
puis paf c'est parti pis là c'est là
c'est la folie le ce a fait en deux mois
on a vendu un demi million kane fait
leurs études sérieuses et à berne
c'est complètement fou puis on a plein
de beaux projets pour la suite des
partenariats intéressante et on a signé
par chip avec les alouettes
pour moi c'est une grande fierté de les
relier team et mes premières amours avec
mes nouvelles armes au sol et enfoncé
pour le stade
on va vendre des canards concession
monde devient partenaire officiel aussi
on va voir d'autres sorte d'intégration
à l'année longue
évidemment de l'affichage d'un stade
toutes sortes de trucs mais mais c'est
vraiment vraiment très simple fait qu on
est vraiment je touche du bois mais très
très bien parti avec atypique le
branding écoulé 6 excellent salle a
explosé tellement rapidement c'est comme
moi j'ai vu ces appareils de ces réseaux
sociaux on travaillait depuis été depuis
longtemps et tu dis tu tires tu dis que
la première conversation ça a été en
janvier 2020 pour qu'on sente en
question tournera en acier rapidement
notre lâcheté mais la vérité c'est qu'au
départ on voulait sortir seul on était
un peu fou mais on voulait sortir ce
pour genre mais pour l'été oui qui kovy
de fait en sorte que ça ralentit de
toutes sortes de production de james
éthique ne serait ce que pour les
canettes ne serait ce que pour
l'emballage
puis avec sur besson a décidé d'élaborer
d'autres saveurs aussi parce qu'au
départ on avait juste un cheval de
bataille plus vraiment une bonne affaire
comme les cartes
et puis on a d'autres qui s'en viennent
[Musique]
deux autres avaient déjà la machine
depuis plusieurs années
il y avait fait cet investissement
l'effectif toute la machinerie qui pour
produire en liquide mais j'ai pas ses
connaissances le jaja prêt à vitesse
grand v avec un ordre mais tout ce qui
est l'élaboration des saveurs tout ce
qui est acquis moins de 10 ou plus
d'arômes de sûreté de 22 ans a à z j'ai
fait partie du processus puis mais les
experts c'est moi je t'ai j'ai amené des
gens aussi pour essayer de goûter pour
voir qui était si moi je tripe là dessus
je tout seul parce qu'il faut quand même
qu'on vendait à la marche mais ceci dit
stratégiquement pression c'est dire
qu'on va sortir fin octobre début
novembre
parce que novembre si gris le monde
veulent essayer d'arriver au fait avec
un petit momentum de santé physique et
mentale les fights vont indifférente
cette année aussi ça va être un bon mois
janvier tout le monde veut te remettre
en shape février sans alcool fait que
l'on se dit comme on lance puis on a
quatre mois où on peut faire du bruit
puis l'ont fait pas juste du bruit on
dit que la patente
puis le c'est une question de même le
faucon catcheur il faut qu'on faut qu'on
en profite pour s'installer puis puis
créer d'autres bons produits au city le
jeudi on sort d'autres saveurs on est là
dedans a présentement le puits on a
établi un standard de qualité
puis on peut pas baisser de 10 au feu
c'est ultra ultra trip 1 de vives sommet
si tu m'avais dit que vous commencez à
béni dans l'agroalimentaire si tu veux
dire à qui j'ai honte mais c'est
vraiment trippant puis c'est un projet
qui me ressemble si j'étais associé avec
une gang de vraiment de créer inquiéter
jonathan romain c'est un homme
d'affaires à saint-hyacinthe
il connaît ça pas tendre sa femme linda
c'est avec elles combattent les biscuits
ou les saveurs elle espère cali dans
tout ce qui arrondit tu le quittes fait
l'équipe étaient 46 moment j'ai troqué
mon équipe de foot yoann et pour
d'autres équipes maintenant c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très mal mais
c'est parti de là
c'est puis y'a rien qui arrive pour rien
dit j'ai aussi regardé beaucoup ce que
font les grands influenceurs aux états
unis les personnels des cas ni les
le rock c'est d'europe que partie cet
équilibre permanent
on se regarde un joe rogan qui est
associée à ces activement avec en est
des suppléments pour le fait que tout ça
fait que fait que je me dis bien comme
ça fait du sens à manado d'arrêter de
juste poussé les produits des autres
pour un montant x qui est quand même
intéressant parce qu'il ya un volet le
créatif assez aussi mais je me dis tout
en fait tu en faisais quand même une
bonne fréquence pour qui j'ai gardé des
partenaires qui sont importants pour moi
que j'ai depuis plusieurs années et
hygiénique d'eau best buy est un nazi en
a qui sont super le fun il y en a
d'autres qui se greffe une fois de temps
en temps puis je mon objectif ce n'est
pas de couper suffit juste faire moins
tant que c'est complémentaire pixels ça
deviens pas non plus du tout match mais
mais je trouve que c'est vers le
conserve au pitch je parle je pense
beaucoup en termes de stratégie de
carrière ou à manille si jamais ce qui
peut arriver
une baisse d'énergie pertes d'emplois
peu importe
puis ultime ans qui coule c'est d'avoir
des trucs qui perdure dans le temps qui
vont au delà de toutes sortes c'est
parce que tu monde le toit soit 70 m de
branding puis j'ai rien contre les télés
les l'émail paiement de ce monde qui
crée un brin alors non les carnets
rompuy ça ça fonctionne ça marche
moi je me voyais mal créer une boisson
etienne c'est vous le voit son boulet
outils fake c'est le jeu par d'atypique
mai 2005 au site il ya d'autres affaires
puis parce que - j'ai beau trip est sûre
tomberez dit par exemple
c'est en bus et 10 heures un sac à dos
cambré dit
j'achèterai pas un sac à dos tomberez
dit parce que j'ai passé là la méthode
tibi toiletter victoire donc à la pop
n'est fait que je voulais à 45 ans je
vois là sur la libye
mais maintenant expliqué compris qui
elle est qu'elle est je vois je vois
aidé à propulser la patente jeudi à
manille ça peut rouler 500 que je vois à
l'avant plan c'est ça l'objectif
je pense que c'est bien parti mais c'est
ce lait ccl la game c'est parce veux pas
que mes temps pour pour avoir un petit
peu cette réflexion mais aussi de mon
côté tu veux pas que que le succès ou
non de ton entreprise dépend que de moi
que de toi ou que aussi d'un algorithme
que tu contrôle pas ces sites à business
et et par ton propre nom ton propre nom
est lié
concrètement à des plateformes de
réseaux sociaux parce qu'elle met donc
demain matin mais ton regard c'est ce
qui me concerne c'est instagram ferme
demain matin bernard j'existe plus le
thé dans la sphère publique m
toi c'est pas par est tout autre quand
même un nom qui est plus connu dans les
médias traditionnels qui qui que le
monde reconnaîtra
ouais mais je pense qu'on a peut-être un
peu la même mentalité mais ce que tu
fais avec la notoriété avec tin vie
publique vont être importantes c'est
parce que ça fait juste surville ce fait
les vagues réseaux sociaux s'il ya une
belle valeur aux réseaux sociaux mais
encore une faute est tributaire d'un
algorithme qui change continuellement
puis tu sais comment amener ça ferme sa
fin fête ses 2 c'est d'abord un plan
pour la suite si vous ce que vous êtes
en train de faire avec avec ses podcasts
lui puisque vous placer comme 7 8 9 le
les premiers 20 30 show tite tu regardes
des vues pu opter content quand il ya 10
de plus de 10 de vue à l'eau puis là
vous êtes rendus à s'en prendre
on entend parler de sans-fil podcaster a
dit que tu parles de podcasts vous êtes
devenu une des références si on s'en est
parlé aussi pendant pendant la livre qui
met 6 avec le travail paie ultime ans je
pense que la game pour déjà qu'ils sont
de notoriété publique c'est de devenir
son propre diffuseur cpie amman et sans
filtre
ils vont être assez grosse île les pas
des jeux pour instagram temps il ya
d'autres plateformes ce regain
d'attention aujourd'hui c'est instagram
tombe de son fils qui demeure le seul a
fait pratiquement même politique c'est
youtube tombe plus tough
oui mais il va avoir d'autres choses
s'il veut sortir et comme ce set cette
game le attendre pour la les plateformes
ont une durée de vie aussi dit on le
remarque facebook est rendue beaucoup
plus âgé parce que tu des gars comme moi
qui ont embarqué dans la game en 2004
2005 quand c'est sorti jeter nos vertus
aux états unis dans le texte apprenait
un des idées ou pour s'inscrire dans ton
adresse courriel
basta je suis rendu à 37 avec des
enfants
ma mère est sur facebook visite et un
public peu fait des affaires la au début
d'instagram on est aidé d'un seul ma
mère aussi rendu sur instagram puis le
mot je vieillis le mon beau fils et sur
un stade en fait qu à manier les
vieilles et ce qui est des nouveaux qui
rendent les tic toc de ce monde les
snapshots fait qu à partir du moment où
tu tombes reine may est exportable
ailleurs ces pilules un des bons modèles
là dedans
j'ai donc ses jo le guen sait qui vient
de signer cet indice qui se peut pas
créative comme ce poste je pensais 2,5
millions 100 millions ses ingrédients
cgt diffusion ça fait dix ans que je te
promets c'est que ça altérée par tout ce
voyage fait la même affaire mais il est
juste une plate-forme pine attitude
hathitrust et puis contre doit être
béton mais même sur tout ce qui est lié
plus besoin de ces facteurs pour vivre
il est lui-même maître chez lui puis on
est dans une période qui permet sa
présente m'affecter moi j'essaie de me
diriger vers leur tranquillement pas
vite en même temps les médias
traditionnels
moi je trouve ça encore coup la fin j'ai
encore ben du fun pis au niveau d
intégration mais je me dis aussi bien le
faire avec des produits qui
m'appartiennent lipides est partenaire
avec qui je m'entends bien fait qui fait
que je suis rendu vers ce fake toutes
les décisions que j'ai prises en cours
de route
ces quatre jours obama ont appelé au
mois de janvier dernier j'aurais pu
faire un banquet pour conques au minimum
pour pousser tomberez intimé à la place
j'ai essayé d'être fidèle avait à mes
objectifs puisque je voulais plus faire
que mais ça me parle moyenne mais si on
va tous ensemble peut-être que ça
pourrait m'intéresser fake fait juste de
faire ce mouvement ça a été la même
chose avec les cinq éditions vendeuse
avec bugatti ce budget il m'a contacté
voulait que j'aide à pousser leurs
brebis gatif j'ai fait le tampon gens
portent des sacs cherche des trippeux de
sac
mais tant qu'à pousser des sacs leur
avenir soit des sacs que j'ai bâti puis
sopi y ont capoté sur l'idée qu'ils sont
par ici mais je ne dirai pas plus at his
sud est où ce sabot brillant ok ça beau
brillant est un groupe qui s'appelle un
johnny thème qui a acheté ce il ya sept
ans je crois 8 à lyon une facture ici et
aussi en floride mais c'est eux qui sont
derrière la ligne de céline dion de
rolling stones maintenant aux sites
ayant cessé je t'ai pas le plus familier
avec l'industrie des super beau paraître
les chipies je touche du bois parce que
c'est à la fois avec atypique paix avec
édition 22
ce sont des c'est vraiment des belles
équipes
on est vraiment dans l'harmonie pédales
c'est dans la transparence dans la
franchise dans le partenariat
puis je sais pas si ça pourrait
fonctionner comme ça avec n'importe qui
type
moi je suis drôle de bibitte aussi quand
j'embarque je suis vraiment enzo j'ai
quand même de l'humilité de kabze j'ai
aucune idée comment ça marche m'explique
moi je réexplique - puis je voterai le
lendemain je pense avoir compris j'ai
pas compris fait qd il faut qu'il prenne
par la main et à moi que vous avez vite
à voici fr vous savez ça fait ch la
d'appui pour de vrai je me dis que c'est
un blessing parce que en temps de
pandémie je peux pas demander mieux les
bons être dans les épiceries juste un
service essentiel s'arrête paul ce qui
est plus difficile qu on en a vendu
beaucoup des sacs aussi les sacs sont
bons sont durables mais mais c'est une
période qui est plus difficile sur l'a8
est aussi en même temps il ya une
augmentation drastique de attendue des
ventes en ligne ça vient pallier un
petit peu de ce côté mais mettons le
t'es pas obligé de rentrer dans trop
dans les détails mais un partenariat
avec occupation double cerveau de ce
lapin parce que moi quand j'ai vu sur
steam et on pourra voir une mini des
deux des coûts pour pour ce genre de
partenariat le savons tous la peine ça a
coûté très cher faut qu'en vendant kg
des sacs l'italie profitent mais je
trouvais que mon grain de sacs associés
fit est vraiment avec la vibe situes tu
sais tu toi que propose le dit c'est
même poussé venue de ces menus des
pointes nous parce que moi je trouve on
dirait que je me fiais beaucoup d'abord
et avant tout sur mon reach un mois puis
magna pas cité puis devant mais je pense
vraiment que ça valait la peine
je pense pour de vrai parce que ça nous
a fait rayonner s'acheter une
crédibilité aussi tips ultime est un peu
surtout vu parce qu'on se bat tout pour
un petit peu d'attention sur les
plateformes entre autres l'instar de ce
monde à partir du moment où tu peux
établir une kabylie t11 créant des
associations des partenariats qui sont
justement crédible qui puisse une
machine c'est tout ce qui est occupation
double effet que fait que l'intégration
d'avoir donné des sacs à des candidats
et des candidates de façon organique
quand même l'envié ils l'ont bien
l'ambiance fini dans le contexte actuel
ça je pense vraiment que cette cinquième
et envisagerait le refaire avec est
typique mettons cette écoute au des
pythies ya plein de boisson qui porte à
oui peut-être
en même temps le voici l'enjeu faut
toujours que tu réfléchisses as tu de
rêve le monde a acheté de quelle façon
pour édition 22 occupation double
fonctionnait bien parce que les gens
sont chez eux ils vont aller ils vont
ils voient les sacs les saxons bad au
voici le site tâche est allé en cinq
minutes s'effectueront le vu les chiffes
souhaite aussi
google est réel on allégée par daniel
quand on voit quand ça fonctionne on
voit quand ça fonctionne pas je capable
d'analyser mes propres poste musée hôtel
sorte de pause ça marche moins
maintenant pour être super les gens
regardent doivent du monde vers le 8
heures c'est plutôt belle et jazz parce
que pour acheter des tickets faut qu'il
y ait eu un écho dans des dépendances
tu vois pas les faits directement tu
sais pas c'est pas musulman puis pour le
moment si ce qu'ils font avec atypique
présentement c'est qu'on n'a pas encore
ouvert la machine c'est l'os qui est ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant
maintenant qu'on pense juste marketing
web ces mots présentement de la part des
voix si une boisson sans alcool qui
goûte bon je vous le disais essayez-le
puis reportages et les gens qui me tag
c'est tout ce que j'ai fait et sa mort
révolutionnaire ce que j'ai fait
fecteau gdg d'aider des stratégies en
banque et j'ai pas fait tant de concours
j'ai pas aux tirs pour voir la machine
mais ton comme les primes ont fait avec
mich début d'été qui ont fondu pour
l'ouvrir en ce moment et non sobey's
piger eux sont comme et on arrête le
site nous qu'un le team parce que c'est
avec le tinal pointe de chips et comme
est une exclusivité avec ce pour deux
raisons au signalement négocié le
marketing de leurs barbes ayons tout
intéressé sopheak marketing sobey's
marketing bowling été inventé par la
station fait tout seul et ça à glace
présente la fecq a que vous n'êtes pas
capables d'en faire racines
on a fait un tabac renau on a des trocs
et des trucs de géo qui partent tous les
jours
puis il y en a au plus bas c'est un
excellent problème à voir mais ça ferait
pas qu'ils ont longtemps mais ça allait
inscrire cinq ans - mais je les ai vécus
avec vega n'est pas plate le dit bako
depuis de fresnes d'affaires là on peut
même plus parler du brain parce que
c'est parce que le monde vont se
déplacent puis le trouve police et sa
pilote et dans la gestion des
frustrations sus ce j'aime pas ça fait
mais on est juste pour une rixe avec sa
petite fille avait dit cosco accroissent
le canada au complet
puis l'heure il n'y a dû recevoir une
shit tonnes de messages parce que
pendant à peu près un mois on parlait
plus le cas d'un christophe rey top tout
comme pas le choix parce que tu veux pas
avoir l'air et pen ont pigé moi j'ai eu
l'air un peu piqué s'est passé le 20
août a commencé sa tournée par partout
je sépare tout en un mois dans ma tête
sont venus chercher les cas hélas comme
la retouche par tous après ça prend un
mois après un mois de roland pilar dans
tous les employés de chaque 3 400 mg ou
du québec
ce pauvre est que savent tout c'est quoi
atypique ce temps artères fait quelqu'un
arrivait recherche de type xo mais j'ai
beaucoup de par ce n'est pas tout les
employés qui sont motivés a trouvé la
réponse filet ce qui était à chelsea que
d'un endroit à l'autre comme on est
rentré rapidement pour profiter du
novembre décembre
cette vague là on n'avait pas des
endroits spécifiques encore on était ce
qu'ils appellent pas fait pendant ce
fait que tant but d'aller mais d'une
place à l'autre le franchisé peut
décider quand je le mets dans les fois
de ta côté des noirs des chocolats il
faut d'abord aider soit à côté des
savons si fait que ces autres des sites
fait pour moi c'est difficile de diriger
du monde dire exactement c'était mais
c'est un extraordinaire défi ça fait
deux mois et demi leur vrai qui encore
une fois je préfère ce problème que
l'autre mais je veux pas que ça dure
longtemps parce que des amanites veut
optimiser son potentiel et le may say
say say say vrais mecs thème quand
étaient venus voler un an et demi après
justement nos titres tels raconté que tu
es dans ta carrière de football qui tu
es petit tu termines objectif c'était
clair puisque je m'entraîne pour ce je
vais faire je ferai un eiffel puis je
fais les étapes au jour le jour pour me
rendre à cet effectif lui pisser clarté
après je disais il faut que c'est
terminé
- clair l'objectif est moins clair la
direction puis mais j'ai quand même
l'impression de tout ce que tu me
racontes débutants tous que c'est assez
clair étienne boulay ou six ans voté
sans le savoir quand même assez bien
qu'elle se faire petit titre vraiment un
contrôle de ce que dans le dollar et on
a foi en disant que tu ais je pense que
je veux mais oui c'est plus clair que
cela était depuis les dernières années
c'est ce que j'avais expliqué c'est que
j'avais comme réorienter ma façon de
penser à la suite et au lieu d'avoir un
objectif d'écouler dit elle à l'envers
j'avais pensé à mes valeurs
comment je prends mes petites décisions
que ce soit encore le cas
québec fecq ailleurs il ya plusieurs un
petit check list de question que je me
pose avant d'embarquer dans quelque
chose c'est quoi maintenant parce que je
suis sûre que celle qui a plein de monde
qui nous écoutent
c'est surtout en ce moment dans le avec
la pandémie avec l'incertitude avec choc
après le monde qu'ils reconsidèrent leur
carrière qui le considèrent qu est ce
qui les rendait heureux dans leur emploi
qu'est ce qui les rendait heureux puis
j'aimerais s'attendent en tentant de
parler d'eux c'est quoi les check list
avant d'embarquer dans un projet quelles
sont les choses qui sont ces points
négatifs est bien compliqué la première
fois si j'en ai fait des partenariats
qui était moyen parce que je pensais à
l'argent d'abord je me disais on a
souvent tendance à se dire je veux bâtir
une espèce de deux pas de tir une santé
financière passage au pouvoir mieux
choisi c'est un petit peu ce que j'ai
fait au site est fake mais c'est pour ça
que je recommande aux gens de foi mais
rapidement tu peux te poser trois
questions
ça me tombe dessus cependant tu pourrais
où je me vais aller dit que ça me tente
pas tu fais la distinction entre les
deux fonds qui passe pour ouvrir faute
et c'est du passé objectivement puis
peut-être même validé avec quelle avec
quelqu'un qui connaît bien ouais c'est
en dessus ça va tu m'aider à avancer
puis si tu payes un papa maman c'est une
autre affaire au niveau des finances où
il faut arrêter de faire l'autruche
comme ça on a tout début la payer puis
amman et on veut tout faire d'argent
peut-être pas de façon démesurée
puis peut-être que oui fake ça me tente
tout pour de vrai ça va tu m'aider à
avancer dans ma vie personnelle ou dans
ma carrière
puis ça vous tue la peine c'est parce
que tout ce que tu acceptes faire en
sorte que tu refuses d'autres choses
aussi je pense beaucoup beaucoup en
gestion de steam et on le situe payant
je vois le d'écouler en termes de temps
et d'énergie fait que donne un exemple
on m'offre un show de télé demain matin
je vois vraiment posé la question parce
que tu sais des tournages c'est des
longues journées c'est plus là qu'il ya
énormément
enfin je te dise pas que je veux dire
non mais je vois vraiment prendre le
temps d'évaluer hockey ces quarante
jours de tournage donc 40 journées où je
peux pas rien faire d'autre
ça vaut dessus la pertinence de
stupéfiants mais moi ce que je voulais
mais c'est un petit peu plus loin puis
j'ai vraiment fait un exercice de
fouiller à l'évent sais quoi mais mes
valeurs c'est qu'est-ce qui me drive
qu'est ce qui peut bien ça ressemble
autour de ça au site et je veux moi j'ai
un besoin de travailler en équipe dans
la vie affective présentement je suis
comblé avec et atypique avec 222 avec
week-end radio faict fait que j'ai
besoin de tripes et enghien fait c'est
pour moi j'ai besoin d'être en mouvement
fait que j'ai besoin de sentir qu
aujourd'hui quand je me coucher je
t'aime si peu plus en avant que je
l'étais hier soir en couches minces et
pour ceux qui comme arrière de demain
ouais c'est ça pis pour ça que j'étais
un peu comme tout quand on se dit au
niveau d'être productif si je me couche
le soir j'ai fait comme j'ai pas
optimiser mon ma productivité ça va
c'est un peu maladif
mais ça va me ronger pilote à faire ce
que je souhaite avoir une liberté
financière parce que quand j'ai une
liberté financière j'ai moins de stress
sur les épaules je trouve que je prends
des meilleures décisions aussi jeu plus
posé dans ma vie puis j'ai une plus
grande facilité je reconnais j'ai plein
de défauts j'ai une plus grande facilité
à dire non ouais recttes et parce que je
n'ai moins besoin
on dirait que le fait de savoir que je
vois être correct pour une coupe des
coupes de rêveur je me dis je pas obligé
de forcer des partenariats qui font pas
de sens ou des idées des moves de terre
mais tu vois ce que tu expliques il je
trouve que c'est marginal fonds à se
connaître
parce que c'est qu'ici on le dépose et
petit pull vert matin en sachant qu'ils
étaient des valeurs pense à chanter tout
ce que tu viennes nous dit nous énumérer
les infectés et est aussi dans une
perspective d'entrepreneuriat mais je
pense que n'importe qui dans sa vie même
c'est pas entrepreneur de ce vraiment se
connaître ça va c'est valeur savoir
qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est que nos
besoins c'est que nous
si on est et grâce à ses solides après
ceux des décisions c'est moins difficile
de prendre des décisions parce que tu le
sais rapidement tout si tu le reconnais
rapidement ces questions soient faits de
palettes moi je connais tes pattes elle
aussi quand tu commences à te mettre
dans le trouble des réactions choquées
et après l'échappée mais moi c'est tout
mon processus de sobriété med tellement
dans l'ain d'autres domaines que la
sobriété direct raison apprendre à le
connaître savoir c'est quoi ta couche
bon on a couché ordinaire puis d'être
frein face à ceux comme tu arrêtes de
brigitte et tu arrêtes de te soucier du
monde qui sont juste titre votre sais
c'est que les gens qui sont
complémentaires et non qui sont comme
tout qui viennent de réconforter dans le
besoin de penser que tu es bon à quelque
chose que tu es petit fake fait pour moi
ça passe par parle c'est qu'il savait
pas que j'étais jeune je fais des
guerres encore des fous et puis je pas
parfait mais ça vraiment ce processus le
d'apprendre à se connaître de se
regarder vraiment comme comment on est
ça va être beaucoup le putois le filon
là où on le pense en termes de carrière
mais en amitié en amour c'est important
iballa bleutée de ce canal savoir qu'est
ce qu'on recherche qu'est ce qu'on a
besoin comme ans qu'on est là que je
sois bon mais tu as raison pitié en
amour c'est donc j'avais j'avais entendu
notre vie je me suis plus un espèce de
coach love coach américain mais il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant
il doit partir du moment où tu te
connais tu connais ton ta partenaire
dans sa façon de donner et recevoir de
l'amour qui va très vite et ben déchets
quand je serai un exemple moi je donne
de l'amour ou la façon tu donnes à
l'amour de la façon que tu aimes le
recevoir moi aussi je n'ai qu'une fille
qui est souvent après mois à
vienne-le-château atm touche mbk jeu
pour moi je ressent de l'amour fait
comme je le ressens de cette façon là
si j'aime quelqu'un je vois faire ce à
la personne qui dans ma tête ça personne
ne comprend
que je donne à l'amour même par exemple
michael c'est pas comme ce qu'elle
reçoit de l'amour est l'américaine nan
mais des bébés qu'elle venait veille
j'ai trouvé un magazine spm avec un
article de foot puis comme text je m'en
fous mais moi je rentrais jamais avec
mes petits cadeaux si je n'avais jamais
trouvé lé langage de l'amour par les
sites pas de cadre ce concept liliane a
sign language l'amour puis exactement de
savoir les signes
qu'est-ce que tu apparais pour nous puis
celle là de l'autre ça permet vraiment
de mieux comprendre l'autre et d'éviter
des conflits parce que c'est c'est la
plus vieille histoire de conflit le
d'espèces d'incompréhension douati les
deux personnes parlent pas le même
langage finalement carrément laisse
comprennent poppy les signes que moi je
te demande l'amour tout et vous à pau
pili sync et toute une demande l'amour
la peau parce qu'on parle pas d'un
mariage c'est aussi tout passe par la
communication ta face au théâtre entre
ce que je pense
ce que je veux dire la façon de 10 puis
la façon que c'est perçu pire reçu il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de layher qui peuvent
amener à ce petit il ya la communication
ça c'est en realbasic tout le québec
fait que cette ati mais t'es gros lot
pour venir
plus tu connais ben oui que tu connais
l'autre avait quitté mieux s'aimer pour
revenir aux décisions pour processus de
tout ce mois des fois je ne suis pas
quelqu'un qui a un jeu pas je pense pas
avoir une arrogance par rapport à ma
confiance en moins ou genre je sais tout
puis c'est sûr que j'ai raison au
contraire le foot je pense a fait en
sorte que je réalise que moi je suis bon
dans certaines affaires
puis j'ai besoin d'autres gens pour
valider et pour m'aider à gagny fake
c'est mon entourage que j'ai gabriel
avec qui je travaille mike à mes amis
les peintres neudorf à ben et andrew
deviennent des conseillers aussi dans
plein d'autres sphères fait que je
valide avec les gens voir ce qu'ils en
pensent
j'écoute leurs input la pression je me
prends une décision de plus réfléchie
possible du fait la force de l'équipe
pour moi est extraordinaire et pitt en a
qui sont pas comme sauter jardiland
masque vraiment c'est comme un one man
army qui qui s'entoure de soldats qui
vont faire comme il veut puissante et
qu'un rapide mais moi c'est un autre
type de leadership comment est ce que
quand même moi mettons j'ai vraiment
venant d'un background sport aussi dans
un contexte de travail
j'ai quand même le le sportif en moi qui
qui qui ressort rapidement inquiet de la
façon mettons quand je faisais quelque
chose de pas correct puis que mon coach
me le disait il me le disait pas en
prenant des tours pour arriver très sûr
que ça fly près que tout le monde non
mon expérience c'est moi autant moins
mais tentez seror con qu'on n'est pas
d'accord sur quelque chose pour les
studios maintenant aller vers la mecque
mais je sais maintenant que si il ya
quelque chose on se dirait tak tak quand
même type
on règlerait aussi rapidement parce que
les deux on est habitués on s'est fait
crier après le plus de fois que j'ai que
je me souviens être des affaires deux
livres par boutleux tipi mois se moquant
je recevais se décolle c'est vrai je
m'accuse moi même je dirais qu'ils
énoncent heures faut que ça change
genre j'ai fait quelque chose ou bien je
prête en désaccord mais je le prends pas
personnellement et ont ainsi est ce que
toi parce que faute c'est encore pire
que dans le sport un dj recommandation
lundi
est ce que toi tu es un peu ce mentalité
l'appui est ce que tu te dis que des
conflits départ ne en appelant à la
battue je ne dirais pas des conflits
mais ben oui parce que c'est tout dit
quelque chose maintenant avec le
background sportif puis tout se dit bien
le disent assez pour personnel c'est
juste acte accès carrossable
moi j'ai mais je pense qu'une qualité
c'est parce que les gens savent que j'ai
pas de jets pas de mauvaises intentions
c gepa de malice en danger j'aime les
gens je souhaite que tout le monde gagne
parce que si tu gagnes petit gang
je veux gagner puis je me sens pas
intimider par le succès d autres au
contraire ça motive puis sam sam
démontre que ça se peut c'était quand
même très
deux fautes sur un olivier primeau qui a
vendu 12 millions de canettes l'année
dernière ben crime
c'est ce que je comprends c'est une
extraordinaire puis je souhaite qu'avant
de 25 l'an prochain puis puis ça ça
motive mais en même temps ultra
compétitif jeu gédéon that en même temps
je le vois avec 2 millions de canettes
puis je me dis qu'il reste moins cher
avec alcool a fait que non mais je suis
ultra compétitif puis je me mets
beaucoup de pression sur les épaules que
je pensais de la bonne pression j'ai des
autres à temps pour moi puis mes
performances mais j'ai des autres
attentes aussi pour les départs
je m'attends à ce que tout le monde soit
aussi all in skippy puis des fois je
veux pas avec le sport c'est surtout en
entreprise mais je réalise que les
choses doivent être amenées autrement
c'est puis des gens que j'admire
beaucoup c'est les frères leclerc c'est
que de l'éclair communication qui sont
propriétaires de trois stations de radio
dont week-end moyens et leur façon
d'adresser des enjeux mais ça me parle
beaucoup
ils sont calmes il l'adresse en te
regardant dans les yeux mais ils le
disent de façon qui est correct faculty
mans je souhaite me diriger vers cette
espèce de gestion là qui est à la fois
autoritaire et à la fois les coups tu
sais juste pas notre temps ce pas le bon
beau métier qui sont comme ces c'est
clair le message est précis concis puis
des fois je me questionne à savoir comme
peut-être qu'il faut se préparer un
petit peu plus avant dans cette
thématique est quelque chose qui de
gosse avec le studio peut-être prend
cinq minutes pour décrire des baux de
pointe pour bien le communiqué c'est
pour pas que lui il reçoit puis qu'ils
fassent comme au shit domino faire il va
le prendre tout croche parce que c'est
plus la façon que je vais sortir c'est
plus une pointe l'ultime à ce que je
veux c'est pouvoir réel dictateur je
veux je veux je veux qu'on avance et ça
fait des fois c'est de prendre de temps
un petit peu plus de préparer un speech
tpiy puis sa gelée pas toujours
parfaitement
fait que ça rejoint aussi ce que tu
disais plus tôt aussi à table on a
affronté toutes disciplines t advient du
port louis d'après ce que tout le monde
paie pas mal poser ta discipline pied
titre ta rigueur parce que moi même j'ai
envie de l'emprunt puis monsieur mouche
j'ai fait c'est rare luxe en relation
des gens envers sir go go go poussé type
dalphond quelques se pousser soi mais de
pousser au taux très bas taux de 2,60 et
j'ai lu beaucoup là dessus aussi
j'ai lu des livres sur l'entreprise
libérer les laits l'espèce de hirschi
horizontale au lieu de vertical
c'est plus j'ai écouté j'ai engagé des
consultants getti j'ai vraiment voulu
comprendre les espèces de hautes charges
verticales peuvent fonctionner peut-être
dans une shop aux dents surtout il ya
dix faire que ça fonctionne plus typique
avec gab que j'ai que j'ai engagé je les
fais ultra organisés puis on fonctionne
en termes de l'objectif de rendement
mais pas en terme de temps par jour avec
ça va arriver des faucons ce papy
j'appelle à 11 heures j'ai quoi la
coiffure je suis maintenant mais tu
comprends votre geste respaud par
rapport à ce parce qu'ultimement on
livre fait que c'est de repenser les
choses autrement pipe ma façon d'être
productif - passe par la discipline peu
un horaire fixe toi ça va peut-être
passer autrement dit il faut que je les
accepte mais aussi pour ma barque avec
toi il faut que je m'attends à ce que tu
peux travailler à ta façon mai puis même
et utilise du réfectoire un peu ce qu'il
faut se poser
chut on a pris notre respiration de
jeunes gens bien plus sujet mais je suis
rassurée en fait j'avais pas qu'avec un
aussi gros engouement pour le sens dans
lequel je suis vraiment si c'est fou je
pensais pas qu'ils aient été à ce point
demande si grande pour ce mais je pense
que c'est une nuance entre le sans
alcool et le bon sens a eu copie pour me
préparer à un métier facile de sortir un
jeu de paume ces puits 2-6 en vigueur
fait je pense qu'on tient un produit qui
est vraiment hot quel type c'était moins
que tout le travail
puis les investissements qui ont fait
depuis plusieurs années à la station
agrobiotex puis de l'autre on travaille
aussi de peaufiner les arts ont pilé
skew mais métis et ça c'est à partir du
moment où tu un produit qui est bon
piqué qui est un peu émettons des tests
à la veille qui est un peu
méconnaissable belle à oued in amenas
mais le monde font bien ça me sert à
quoi
d'abord tu veux te saouler joseph vaut
pas là mais c'est juste le bout de fil
et festif
puis demain pour réveiller avec le recul
atteint dans le cul tu sais même si tu
en as juste prix 2 c'est une super bonne
alternative tipi la façon qu'on avait
deux choses qu'on vous l'évaluez
incertain en sortant les produits la
première phase et on va le savoir
moi j'étais conscient que rapidement
avec man autorités avec le ridge avec
qui j'étais capable de faire du bruit
puis que j'allais draps vue du monde à
aller l'essayer pour qu'il reprenne là
ils vont tous leur hache de guerre
féclaz on voit sur ces les gens
rachètent l'autre affaire qu'on évalue
et aussi c'est qu'on la sortie de deux
façons les quatre packs d'une seule
saveur on n'a pas encore de mix de
saveurs où les saints go unit fait qu au
début ce qui se vendait plus de 6 mo et
1 go et la serap des cas pas que l'on
reçoit des demandes et allez vous vendre
des cadeaux vous allez voir les caisses
de 24 ans comme c'est trippant fait que
pour nous c'était moins que celle
acquise au 10 juillet bon l'autre chose
qu'on voulait évalue aussi c'est quand
il sort quatre sortes savoir mais tu ne
t'es jamais une c'est dans le pipi sur
120 kw ben en fait mal dans le temps
dans l'ailé les deux premiers mois
c'est complètement fou d'un 4 savoir sur
cherche utopiquement 25,5 on est à 28 26
24 22 c'est fou rire le premier étant le
le mojito gin tonic de ses spreads pire
encore c'est est ce que vous pensez que
c'est moi je pensais que le gento à la
être numéro un numéro un
le mojito surprenamment c'est celui qui
me faisait le moins de tripes et puis ce
qui est drôle aussi c'est que linda est
arrivé avec l'idée du sprint s'est fait
claire bon ça faisait du sens parce que
je me dis mettons qu'on pense goffi
gento rome court répit c'est peut-être
un petit peu plus ces stéréotypes et
garçons que je me dise bri - tôt
peut-être un petit peu plus stéréotypé
fais moi jarrete black hat rien fait que
ce prix était pas populaire je vous dis
c'est quoi ces sorties d'avant dernier 2
c'est populaire les gens parfaits
instance et mes préférés c'est moi j'ai
fait mon petit gars de temps à table se
trouve celui qui s'agencent le mieux
avec même est fait pour le moment si je
touche du bois on dirait que tout
fonctionne avec atypique puis l'objectif
c'est encore et toujours de créer un
produit que le monde vont continuer
d'aimer l'on commence à recevoir des
suggestions et vous pensé à ma carrière
sangria vous pensé de la faim fait qu'on
a plein plein de beaux projets pour pour
la suite cette fois les bons mots au bon
moment saint genès dénaturer puissant
jamais c'est comme nuire à ce que le
monde woerth et ses broches je te
maquilles à cette mouvance le parc on se
mouille - de cana font tester le haut un
peu plus loin je voulais ça vient à la
sarine et tenir la santé
toi tu imagines que tu vas me répondent
tout le meti toi quatre ans ébriété
j'imagine ça complètement changé d'avis
à tapoter je faisais au niveau de ma
santé au niveau de this tout ce que tu
dit le vécu dans ton trois mares
confinement moi je le vis maintenant
c'est puis c'est loin derrière mais tu
vas voir des matins où je me réveille
fatigué brûlé mais jamais que c'est pas
la même c'est pas la même chose pas même
brûlé c'est sûr que si je compare à des
matins où j'ai signifié de la nuit j'ai
pas dormi puis le faut que les faits
relatés les chassant la joie c'est comme
ça c'est pour le vrai je veux plus
jamais revivre ça mais même des petites
soirées ou jetés
cette erreur mais capable de me
contrôler puis le lendemain c'est juste
un petit peu pas qui pilote tout ça
c'est terminé c'est puis faites au
niveau physique et mental
puis au niveau c'est niaiseux mais
l'alcool ça coûte des sous puis souvent
tu va dépenser en dehors aussi de cépie
le bon ben on n'a plus l'occasion de
sortir métier l'alcool a embarqué en
restaurer et à bouteilles de vin qui va
coûter 40 pièces à l'eso qui vont coûter
120 ou 160 au resto le va sortir après
dans un bar lethenet tu t'en vas à la
banque et tout ce que dépense en dehors
aussi fait financièrement de couper
l'alcool devient un avantage toi ça fait
4 1 puis c'est pour la vie il faut - il
faut parce que j'ai posté fallait que
j'arrête c'est pillet puis ouest pour la
vie c'est plus jeune et la plus belle
avec eux qui arrivent ce que je réalise
que tout ce que j'ai aujourd'hui dans le
biais d'un doigt les relations avec ma
famille je le dois à ce gt après tout
crédible il ya des relations que j'ai ce
qu'un petit qui sont peut-être paraître
a pas dit c'est correct et may hamm
souvenant d'où je viens et à quel point
j'avais un mal de vivre
puis en me rappelant que tabarnouche
aujourd'hui c'est cool ce que j'ai grâce
à ce ça fait en sorte que je me
convaincs de pau bord aujourd'hui que je
me dis mais ça m'amènerait quoi c puis
si je m'ouvre la porte a peut-être après
dix ans je verrai je déjà dans mass
effect morpho qu'il faut juger par la
rechute pitt est la plus belle affaire
qui m'est arrivé c'est de rechuter si
j'avais fait un an de sobriété je pense
qu'en 2010 2015 2016 mais tant pis 2015
je pense plus puis après ça j'ai rechuté
pendant 1h liste des galas steppiques à
zürich et quand je rechute moi je
rechute exactement où j'ai laissé c'est
ce qu'ils disent
pour fait qu'au lieu d'avoir honte de
mesdames messieurs je me dis que j'ai
perdu un à ma vie je décide que c'est un
avantage extraordinaire je me trouve je
me convaincs suffoquer mais je me
convaincs que je me trouve que je change
d'avis qu'une rechute
parce que ça ça fait en sorte que je
n'ai vécu je sais que je vais puel est
l'homme je sais où ça mène
puis faites fait que je me trouve
chanceux de me remettre à face puis
d'avoir ce cap et des relations aussi
faut qu'il y ait eu des moments des
forces que c'est plus tough la sobriété
est ce qui m'attendait dans ces quatre
années le puits si oui c'est quoi les
facteurs qui font que ils crient
aujourd'hui secteur ouais je me souviens
de quelques événements seul et moins
maintenant qu'on est toutes un
confinement métis est arrivé souvent que
c'est moi je me suis indépendant les
peut-être sept premiers mois jusqu'à ce
que je me permettent de ressortir au
resto parce que sinon ça me faisait
penser à l'idée que je vais encore
maintenant quand je m'attends dans un
cet été on peut aller dans les restos le
tube je veux pisser dans un resto
j'étais réflexe de penser qu'à moi j'ai
des vieux flash de ce que je faisais
naître leur surface pour que je sais ça
commence mais mais aussi des mamans
c'est plus tard ouais
oui c'est sûr c'est l'heure des outils
qu'il faut que tu appliques ses pépites
moi je réalise avec les avec les
quelques petits 24 heures que j'ai
accumulée ce que faut toujours quelques
petits spots dans journée que je me
rappelle que je pense que c'est fake
c'est à dire garder contact envoyer un
petit texto à un autre monde
aa ou ak quelqu'un que chez qui elle
même espèce dangereux - puis juste
support permet pas de calais je me
souviens que untel ou untel avec pour
but aujourd'hui c'est fake
si je me tiens juste avec du monde comme
vous qui n'êtes pas dangereux ammann est
le cerveau ils votent rejointe aussi te
convaincre que tu es possible
c'est ce que ça fait aussi ce que tu dis
je considère que ce jeu pendant rue j'ai
encore une maison j'ai encore une job
fait quid des journées qui sont plus
durs souvent je le vois venir un peu à
l'avancé puis ça revient apprendre à se
connaître des faux juste un petit peu
plus à pic ou d'enjeu plus impulsifs
dans mes impulsions juste un peu plus
négatifs dans mes pensées mais là j'ai
vite des endroits qui sont qu'ils sont
roms mais je me souviens de
je n'aimerais pas non métier j'avais co
animer un événement mondain avec une une
personne puis puis quand ça s'est
terminé
elle est partie sud parité avec son
homme de l'époque petit il y avait plein
de plaintes coupe des trucs comme sopi
ça faisait peut-être un deux ans que
j'avais pas consommées puis là j'ai eu
une décision à prendre j'ai fait comme
instrument qu'est ce que je fais puis je
suis parti j'ai trouvé ça vraiment dur
de partir puis tout le long d'un loto
j'étais à l'envers titi conduite le
volant de même trop lente à vie ou est
ce que tu vois de tes yeux de la peau
d'un stand stand e15 moi mais je m'étais
même des comme dans le sport
moi je m'étais dit un jour ça va
m'arriver en revoir et puis c'est fou on
observe que fini juste témoigner à quel
point c'est fort qu'avant mais quand je
rentre à la maison j'ai ressenti un
soulagement
je dormais plus de cross le lendemain
quand je veux se réveiller à 7 8 ans à
partir de chansons rangement mais parce
que je me suis au lieu de céder footy
peut on joue taux des femmes dans notre
tête on joue des scénarios je dois le
vrai c'est quelqu'un me dit nesbitt
quelqu'un dans une fille dans un mythe
et qui maudit ce canton scénario par
haddy fait l'exercice etienne passe à
travers toutes les simples bons jeux
ceux qui tentent fait maintenant qu'en
partant dissidentes au jeu me dit
j'arrête chez un dealer
mais là je vois consommé dans le genre
en me rendant je vois je vois aller ou
acquis le voyage voyage et le hockey
apprécié dans une radio je rende la
maison le phosphate semble ingérer un
bris lazio tout le monde se couche le
ch'ti match de repos là trois heures du
matin jusqu'à pas de former lèvres j'ai
radio d'être finie tchèque un parc de
mardi ça me tente pas fake fait que
céder des petits réflexes que tu après
avoir mais évidemment comme tout le
monde des foyers des départs sont plus
difficile évidemment comme tout le monde
des fois je vous regarde et facebook
puis facebook
c'est rare que tu vois quelqu'un qui est
sous pie kiki et risque qui voit ce film
est toujours festif tu me bof il pleut
ça l'a vraiment l'fun petit commerce est
long mais c'est cette pas tomber dans le
pathos
ça fait passer jégo s'appelle sang neuf
mais la piste un certain goût dans le
fond c'est un drame heure dans un bain
de métal puis au début du film commence
à perdre
l'audition qui dans le fond au début tu
le vois tu vois le goty l'état tout il
ya deux là mais au début du film du
genre excès de la matière sont smoothie
tpiy malgré qui l'amène à matha saint
gaudinois qui était chez tous guéris
piteux prix commencent à perdre
l'audition publiquement sa capote et
pilote apprend que dans le fond c'est ce
que j'ai fait quatre ans qu'ils aient
clinton qui était héroïnomane pileux les
forces a capoté à cause de tuer une
enfance pas un film qui parle de venir
soit parce que le flingue devient sous
le tipi ce point punch mais un film qui
parle de devenir saut c'est un film qui
parle de dépendance et parce que celui
tout il y avait séché tous les deux ça
allait bien au jour le jour mais ce
cette difficulté de cette épreuve le
fait que le marché est ici l'élément
déclencheur qui fait que propre
peut-être faire chuter matin on le sait
on vraiment dans le fond tu es c'est
quelque chose de difficile tu vois livre
il va il faut juste me top 6 le pré sa
blonde et comme ac haut débit à capable
parce qu'une top le thé le genre relaxe
l'été mais après tu comprends que ce
parce que c'est comme la première étape
puisque pour ce que ces métis et quant
au second qui sont quittes connaît ce
qu'ils voient ces petits patins le
peuvent les faire remarquer car toutes
les remarques pomme était celle avantage
avons fait un thérapie ou en tout ces
types qu'on éduque sur certaines
affaires mais tu sais ce qu'ils me
disent débité particulièrement au début
pour pas retombée c'était toutes les
fois où tu vis des gros gros buy vient
de signer un nouveau contrat vous venez
d'être utile à l'aide les meilleurs
chiffres d' écoute en partenaire vous
appelle sais comment je vais te
parthenay annuel à ces cas là son coût
de toutes les fois où tu as des débords
mortalité dans ta famille quelque chose
d'un gros gros dans sois prudent
la fatigue et la faim aussi son décès
tout d'aider en fait les gros arrêts
les gros bras la fatigue la faim
contribuer à l'impulsivité et à chaque
fois qu'ils étaient en situation tu peut
accentuer tonton impulsivité tout mais
risque fait que céder des patins ou tu
fais comme moi ok gestion des émotions
c'est ça revient ce brin de revient à
l'équilibré qu'on a parlé en début de
podcasts de trouver l'équilibré d'avoir
une discipline d'enfants c'est pas dans
ses bras une vie bien équilibrée et
disciplinée qui vont critiquer votre
rigueur une ruche dans les journaux tous
s'entraînent ce pauvre est que j'allais
faire un training d'après joie de cetto
de bien marché et a traîné sa série
ouais ça revient ça revient au jeu avant
de laisser allez savoir
c'est quand tu vas continuer ou 3
reprend les conseils de coups que tu
faisais le début de confinement parce
que moi comme si j'étais j'ai apprécié
j'ai apprécié vraiment oui je trouve que
ken motive à meschers est peut-être un
humoriste mais pas mal le premier
confinement les conseils de coupe ça
c'était les vidéos qui me faisait le
plus rire montgueux un crâne est
tellement attendu pendant ces six années
fait injuste pour être cave dans le sud
de dynamique à table on s'est tellement
à ce qu'elles savaient pas pauvre et
j'aime pas que j'assure prête toujours
plus vrai quand je fais conseil de copie
privée qu est comme si quelque chose de
pilar se voit l'évolution je n'ai jamais
fait de leur usine
pis rendu à la fin c'est juste qu'un
conseil de communauté
juste le palan kscm laisse aller mais
j'en ai tellement entendu parler mais
cet été je m'avoue est-ce que j'en
entends parler puis j'ai reçu beaucoup
de demandes dans le quintette pour
commencer puis pour de vrai j'avais plus
de temps à faire confiance à faire des
conneries que d'un point que j'en ai
lleurs mais peut-être l'année mais je
suis ça m'a frappé cet été je mange ta
ville dans
un resto puis je sors pour me diriger
vers mont athos et jean rené lévesque
puis un doute qui fait qu'en bio ayew au
milieu de gamme il parle en arrêt il
s'est aucunement cetin blick je vous ai
loué au lieu de garde est la dose de
conseils de coûts il faut que nous les
russes mais crytek uk c'est la fois
boujari photo n'est pas courant dans son
film les conseils de coupe qui fait que
c'est drôle ça c'est un panier pis si
j'essaie de en fait j'essaie d'être moi
même sur les réseaux sociaux le plus
possible des fous puis je me pose
souvent la question savoir comme ce que
je pense à votre sens de la valeur à
quelqu'un juste et clairement juste un
divertissement mais ces dépenses est
parfait pour la période
ouais enfin confinement tout le monde
sait que t'es réveillé tablons pour
t'assurer qu'il soit bien huilée
[Rires]
respectable si rare la gamme de domaines
la franchise tout ce qu'on est des êtres
qui se moque et enregistré ce petit
pécule
mais le monde me connaît bien jeudi des
affaires qui se peuvent pas défaut mais
ils savent que j'ai pas de mêlée fermée
une bonne place merci infiniment ça vous
autrefois n'est vraiment cool très
montrer que vous fait plaisir
merci